bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur Public
Sénat elle traque les économies partout
où elle se trouve elle distribu les bons
et les mauvais points il s'agit bien sûr
de la Cour des comptes hier les sages de
la rue Combon ont présenté leur rapport
annuel un rapport très attendu et cette
année ils ont décidé de se focaliser
particulièrement sur des aspects de la
vie courant des Français alors on peut
citer pmel et bien la gestion de l'eau
les maternités le Musem à Marseille ou
encore le cru autant d'éléments où il y
a de forts gisements d'économie selon
les sages et comme le veut la tradition
républicaine le premier président de la
Cour des comptes Didier MIGO est venu ce
matin au Sénat pour déposer ce fameux
rapport devant les sénateurs l'occasion
de prononcer un discours pour rappel
bien le travail conjoint entre le Sénat
et la Cour des comptes prendront
également la parole Gérard Larcher
président du Sénat ainsi que les
présidents de la commission des finances
et de celle des affaires sociales je
vous laisse découvrir ça tout de suite
dans
l'hémicycle la séance est
ouverte Luissier voulait veuillez faire
entrer monsieur le Premier Président de
la Cour des
comptes c'est le rapporteur général
quic monsieur le Premier Président mon
le rapporteur général c'est toujours un
grand plaisir de vous accueillir dans
cet hémicycle pour la la remise du
rapport annuel de la Cour des
comptes le Sénat et la Cour des comptes
entretiennent des liens anciens des
liens étroits notablement renforcé par
la révision constitutionnelle de 2008
qui a développé le rôle de votre
juridiction en matière notamment
d'assistance au Parlement le Sénat
lui-même avait souhaité à cette occasion
introduire le principe selon lequel la
Cour des comptes contrib vu à
l'évaluation des politiques
publiques aujourd'hui nous nous
félicitons tous au sein de cette
assemblée de pouvoir bénéficier de votre
expertise pour nos travaux de contrôle
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
contrôle de l'exécution des lois de
finances contrôle de l'application des
lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale ainsi que d'évaluation des
politiques
publiques monsieur le Premier Président
je tiens d'abord à vous remercier
personnellement de votre présence et
pour vos nombreuses interventions devant
nos commission par lesquelles vous venez
régulièrement rendre compte avec vos
collègues des travaux de la
cour je sais que naturellement vos
anciennes fonctions notamment comme
président de la commission des finances
de l'Assemblée nationale fa que vous
êtes particulièrement sensible aux
préoccupations du Parlement vous Moné à
travers les rapports prévus par la LOLF
dont vous avez été chacun le sait
l'instigateur avec notre ancien collègue
Alain Lambert et les nombreux rapports
publics thématiques que la Cour produit
chaque année vous avez également à cœur
de répondre aux nombreuses demandes
d'assistance qui am notamment de notre
commission des finances ou de notre
commission des affaires sociales
celles-ci ont pu bénéficier cette année
encore
de votre concours de votre expertise
pour l'exercice de leur fonction de
contrôle une fonction essentielle au
Sénat je le rappelais hier soir en
conférence des
présidents je pense au rapport portant
pour la commission des finances
notamment sur la protection judiciaire
de la jeunesse sur les contrats de
projet état région ou sur l'Agence
nationale de la rénovation urbaine je
pense pour la commission des affaires
sociales sur les maternités les
relations conventionnelles entre
l'assurance maladie et les professions
libérale de santé ou l'Association
Nationale pour la Formation
Professionnelle des Adultes un débat
sera d'ailleurs organisé en séance
publique lors d'une prochaine semaine de
contrôle sur le sujet des maternités la
Conférence des Présidents en a décidé
ainsi hier soir les observations constat
préconis qui émane de vos travaux nous
sont très utiles pour remplir notre rôle
de parlementaire pour mieux légiférer et
mieux contrôler l'examen minutieux des
crédits a la gestion des services
publics auquel la Cour procède
régulièrement et son regard a serré sur
l'efficacité des politiques publiques
qui montre parfois un certain décalage
entre les objectifs souhaités et les
résultats obtenu constitue une
information précieuse tant pour le
citoyen que pour les parlementaires
chargés d'élaborer la
loi cette collaboration me semble
aujourd'hui d'autant plus crucial que la
situation des finances publiques demeure
préoccupante je suis convaincu que nous
devons progresser vers une réduction des
dépenses publiques et quelques chiffres
de comparaison avec d'autres pays de la
zone euro sont
éloquants et dans le même temps nous
devons engager les réformes
structurelles vigoureuses qui doivent
permettre de créer la croissance dans
notre pays a tant besoin il n'est ni
concevable ni souhaitable que le déficit
public français reste durablement deux
fois plus élevé que la moyenne de la
zone euro je l' évoqué jeudi dernier
avec le président Junker à Bruxelles par
ses travaux la Cour des comptes peut
contribuer à cette ambition la remise du
rapport annuel de la Cour est toujours
attendu bien sûr pour son analyse de la
situation générale des finances
publiques et son éclairage sur l'action
publique mais également pour l'analyse
des suites données par les
administrations les collectivités et les
autres organismes publics contrôlés aux
observations et recommandations qui a
été formulé dans le passé la
représentation nationale est attentive
aux suites et progrès qui résulte de vos
travaux c'est donc avec intérêt et
attention monsieur le Premier Président
que nous allons dès à présent vous
écouter présenter le rapport annuel de
la Cour des comptes avant d'entendre
madame la la présidente de la commission
des finances et monsieur le président de
la commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le Premier Président vous avez
la
parole
monsieur
le
président madame la présidente de la
commission des finances monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs tout
d'abord merci monsieur le Président de
vos propos
bienveillant à mon endroit et à celui de
la cour c'est c'est toujours avec grand
plaisir que je me rends devant vous pour
rapporter les travaux qui sont les
nôtres alors même s'il ne s'agit plus de
la seule publication de la cour le
rapport public annuel reste la plus
emblématique de sa mission
d'information des décideurs publics que
vous êtes et des citoyens les
thématiques
abordées dans plusieurs de ces chapitres
traduisent le souci de couvrir des
problématiques et des enjeux proches du
quotidien de nos concitoyens la qualité
des services effectivement rendu les
performances réelles mesuré à l'ône des
objectifs de politique publique et la
dépense effectué mais avant
d'évoquer les observations et
recommandations du rapport public annuel
2015 je veux revenir rapidement sur la
contribution des juridictions
financières aux efforts de modernisation
des services publics profondément
attaché au principe de séparation des
pouvoirs les juridictions financières
sont au service de la République dans le
respect des textes fondamentaux qui
régissent leur mission elles apportent
une contribution indépendante grâce à
une
programmation libre de leurs travaux et
à la publicité donnée à leurs
observations elles veulent de manière
constructive répondre à vos demandes
d'enquête soutenir également dans leur
démarche celles et ceux qui ont pour
objectif d'améliorer l'action public en
2014 la Cour des comptes a rendu publi
63 travaux au-delà des six rapports
annuels sur les finances publiques elle
a réalisé en 2014 17 enquêtes à la
demande de l'Assemblée nationale ou du
Sénat elle a été auditionnée une
cinquantaine de fois cette mission
d'assistance au Parlement la cour y est
très attachée vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le Président et s'efforce
d'être utile à la représentation
nationale et je vous ai également
adressé 25 référés qui ont été
communiqués aux membres du gouvernement
et C rapports particuliers concernant
des entreprises publiques les
juridictions financière veillent à
exercer leur mission avec un haut niveau
d'exigence éthique et professionnelle
comme le législateur l'avait demandé en
votant fin 2011 une disposition expresse
en ce sens j'ai arrêté en décembre
dernier le recueil des normes que les
équipes de contrôle doivent respecter
conformément aux règles nationales et
internationales en vigueur et ce
comporte en annexe notre charte de
déontologie et ces documents sont
accessibles sur le site internet de la
cour et peuvent être consulté par tous
élus agents public citoyens al si elles
sont plus souvent conduites à souligner
les
disfonctionnement les juridictions
financières savent aussi reconnaître les
efforts consentis pour améliorer
l'action publique pour reconnaître
l'utilité de l'action publique le
rapport met ainsi l'accent sur le suivi
des recommandations et développe deux
situations en progrès grâce à des
dispositions législatives récemment
votées la cour est à ce titreevenu sur
la gestion des avoirs bancaires et les
contrats d'assurance vie en désérrance
et sur le recours au chômage
partiel dans les deux cas le législateur
a largement repris à son compte les
propositions formulées par la
juridiction et la cour continuera
d'assurer un suivi de la mise en œuvre
des dispositifs qui doivent être
complétés au niveau
réglementaire ces propos préliminaires
achevés j'envens au message porté cette
année par le rapport de la Cour un
décalage est trop
souvent observver je me distingue de ce
que vous avez dit monsieur le Président
vous avez dit parfois euh nous nous
permettons de dire trop souvent observer
entre les annonces les engagements et
les résultats réellement obtenus il est
préjudiciable à la crédibilité des
politiques publiques certains services
publics doivent être gérés avec un
niveau d'exigence plus élevé et des
marges d'économie et d'efficience
existent et peuvent être mobilisé pour
le redressement de nos comptes publics
mais aussi pour des politiques publiques
mieux ciblés plus adapté aux besoins et
aux attentes de la société alors nous
accumulons les déficits depuis près de
40 ans depuis 1974 sans discontinuer
s'agissant du budget de l'État le
chômage demeure à des niveaux
inquiétants la part de nos dépenses
publiques dans le PIB est parmi les plus
élevés sans que les résultats soient à
la hauteur
et dans ce contexte l'effort devrait
être plus résolu en faveur d'une gestion
plus rigoureuse des finances et des
services publics davantage
tourné vers la recherche d'efficacité or
cette année encore la Cour observe à de
nombreuses reprises un décalage entre
les engagements pris les objectifs
affichés les moyens qui leur sont
consacrés et les résultats obtenus et
c'est le premier message de la cour la
confiance dont jouit notre pays dans les
instances politiques économiques
financières au niveau européen et
international est étroitement lié à la
crédibilité de sa politique budgétaire
alors l'actualité récente
montre que les débats de politique
économique sont nourris quant à
l'approche à retenir dans un contexte
encore difficile et alors que les dettes
public de plusieurs États européens dont
le nôtre continue de se creuser or le
rôle de la Cour des comptes n'est pas
bien sûr de trancher ces débats il n'est
pas de se substituer au pouvoir
politique dans la prise de décisions qui
vous appartient les choix à retenir ou
les engagements à prendre vis-à-vis de
nos partenaires en revanche le rôle de
la Cour est bien d'informer sur la
situation et les perspective des
finances publiques et sur le respect des
engagements pris la cour fonde ainsi son
appréciation sur une réalité observable
les lois que vous votez les hypothèses
du gouvernement les résultats des lois
de finances ainsi que la statistique
publique nationale et européenne et
comme chaque année dans un chapitre de
son rapport public annuel la cour livre
à nos concitoyens à vous-même
son regard sur la situation des finances
publiques alors deux grandes
observations s'en dégage cette année le
mouvement de réduction des déficits
s'est interrompu en
2014 la capacité de la France à tenir
ses engagements reste incertaine en 2015
le chapitre consacré aux finances publ
met en évidence le dérapage des
prévisions successives de déficit public
pour 2013 et 2014 le mois
dernier lors de l'audience solennelle de
rentrée de la Cour l'opération vérité de
septembre 2014 par laquelle le
gouvernement selon nous tardivement a
reconnu la réalité de l'empleur des
déficits les résultats de 2014 devraient
être meilleurs que la prévision de 4,4 %
inscrite dans la loi de finances de
décembre 2014 mais quand bien même il se
rapprocherait par exemple de 4,1 % cela
resterait encore bien supérieur au 3,6 %
s prévu initialement et en tout état de
cause ces résultats ne marqueraient pas
une amélioration par rapport à 2013
puisque 2013 il y avait également
4,1 au contraire de ce qui se passe dans
pratiquement tous les autres pays de
l'Union européenne dont le déficit
dépasse 3 %. or malgré un objectif de
réduction du déficit limité par rapport
à celui prévu initialement en 2014 la
capacité de la France à tenir ses
engagements reste incertaine pour 2015
la cour identifie en effet plusieurs
risques en dépens comme en recette lié
notamment aux perspectives de baisse de
l'inflation un premier risque pèse sur
la réalisation des 21 milliards d'euros
d'économie annoncé en avril 2014 ces
économies sont
conçus pour leur très grande part je le
rappelle non comme une diminution de la
dépense publique mais comme un effort de
ralentissement par rapport à son
évolution tendantielle un second risque
pèse sur le montant des recettes
fiscales attendu pour 2015 et le risque
ne se situe pas comme les autres années
sur la croissance ou les hypothèse
d'élasticité des recettes fiscales mais
là encore sur l'inflation prévue les
lois financières s'appuent sur une
hypothèse de 0,9 % largement supérieur
aux dernières prévisions la Commission
européenne parle même d'une inflation
voisine de 0 % pour la France les
pouvoirs publics doivent se pencher sans
tarder sur les enjeux que soulève la
période actuelle de très faible
inflation à laquelle nous n'étions pas
habitués il faut le reconnaître elle
remett en cause les perspective
d'équilibre des finances publiques et le
cadre budgétaire triénal sur lequel
repose notamment le budget de l'État et
longame si les risques identifiés se
concrétisent le retour sous le seuil de
3 % du PIB en 2017 serait probablement
compromis à cet horizon la dette
publique pourrait approcher voire
dépasser 100 % et l'équilibre structurel
des comptes publics ser serait encore
repoussé au-delà de 2019
attention à ne pas se laisser abuser par
le très faible niveau des taux d'intérêt
auquel l'État se finance actuellement la
dette supplémentaire que nous continuons
d'accumuler va devoir être financée
refinancé pendant de nombreuses années
elle ne le sera sans doute pas
éternellement au taux exceptionnellement
bas que nous connaissons aujourd'hui et
ces déficits et cette dette
supplémentairire pèseront lourdement sur
les générations futures et sur les
marges de manœuvre des gouvernements
dans l'avenir nous sommes confrontés à
une situation paradoxale en ce moment la
dette augmente et la charge de la dette
diminue mais il faut faire attention
cela peut ne pas durer le rééquilibrage
durable de nos finances publiques dépend
bien sûr des choix de politiqu
économique susceptible de renforcer le
potentiel de croissance de l'économie il
implique aussi de faire des choix clairs
pour une organisation plus performante
des services publics une meilleure
répartition des compétences entre les
uns et les autres et des moyens et
l'ensemble de ces choix ne s'impose pas
au nom d'une contrainte subie ou importé
il s'impose si j'ose dire de l'intérieur
si notre pays veut préserver sa
souveraineté c'est-à-dire précisément sa
capacité à faire des choix les
politiques de rabau ne peuvent pas tenir
lieu de stratégie de redressement des
comptes publics ni surtout d'horizon
pour les services publics de demain dans
le rapport public de cette année la cour
s'interroge à plusieurs occasions sur la
cohérence de l'action de tel ou tel
organisme public avec les objectifs
visés parfois même elle met en doute la
conduite de l'action publique au regard
des objectifs qu'elle est censé remplir
ce sont en effet les résultats atteints
par une politique publique qui
garantisse sa crédibilité donc con
citoyen exige à juste titre puisqu'ils y
contribuent financièrement que l'action
publique débouche sur des résultats
tangibles concrets dans la vie de tous
les jours et cela est encore loin d'être
le cas au regard des crédits consacrés
de nombreux sujets de ce rapport
touchent à la vie quotidienne des
habitants que ce soi les transports
l'eau l'électricité l'emploi le sport ou
la vie étudiante je ne les citerai
évidemment pas tous mais je vais évoquer
devant vous les exemples les plus
saisissant prenons d'abord le cas des
agences de l'eau principaux financières
de la politique de l'eau en France elle
collectent des taxes ou redevance dans
le respect théorique du principe
pollueur payeur en réalité
ces redevances en sont largement
déconnectées et ceux qui polluent le
plus ne sont pas ceux qui paient le plus
2è exemple le bilan de l'ouverture du
marché de l'électricité à la concurrence
et dans les fait contrasté plusieurs
dispositions du projet de loi sur la
transition énergétique dont vous
débattez en ce moment vont dans le sens
des préconisations de la cour sur ce
sujet la gestion des trains Intercités
offre un exemple d'atermoimement entre
volonté affichée de réforme et
indécision persistante et préjudiciable
au servicees public et la cour appelle
les pouvoirs publics à sortir de
l'impasse pour offrir à ces lignes un
horizon
pérenne dans un contexte économique
difficile des signes de défiance sont
perceptibles à l'égard du secteur public
c'est pourquoi dans son deuxè message la
cour veut insister sur l'impératif de
rigueur et d'exigence qui s'impose aux
agents et aux services publics la Cour a
voulu rendre public des cas et des
situations qui appellent plus de rigueur
et de retenue dans l'usage des donniers
publics ou dans les comportements sans
préjudice des irrégularités qu'elle
pourra constater et qui pourraiit être
sanctionné par ailleurs dans son rapport
la Cour évoque d'abord la mise en place
dans le secteur public d'un dispositif
importé du secteur privé et qui peut se
justifier dans un secteur concurrentiel
l'attribution gratuite d'action aux
salariés de CDC entreprise filiale à 100
% de la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation c'est un cas de dérive
choquant qui révèle plusieurs
dysfonctionnements et au regard du
caractère tout à fait anormal de
l'ensemble de cette situation la Cour de
discipline budgétaire et financière a
été saisie par le procureur général par
ailleurs la Cour a
procédé à un contrôle de suivi sur le
Conseil économique social et
environnemental elle s'est à nouveau
intéressé à la gestion budgétaire et
comptable de l'institution à sa gestion
du personnel et au régime spécial de
retraite des anciens conseillers
l'exigence de rigueur concerne aussi les
collectivités
territoriales après examen de plusieurs
contrats de partenariat signés par des
collectivités territoriales depuis 2004
la Cour recense les conditions qui
devrai à l'avenir être réuni si l'on
veut avoir recours à ce mode dérogatoire
de gestion des services publics la cour
c'est également penché sur les
compléments de rémunération dont
bénéficient les fonctionnaires d'État
outreem une réforme de ce système à bout
de souffle apparaît souhaitable dé
marges importantes d'économie d' acité
d'efficience existe et doivent être
davantage mobilisé c'est le troisème et
dernier message de la cour le maillage
des services publics doit mieux répondre
aux besoins et aux attentes ainsi la
révision du réseau et des missions des
œuvres universitaires et scolaires
apparaît indispensable à la fois au
regard de l'offre territoriale des choix
d'investissement de la simplicité et de
l'efficacité du ciblage de son
action un service public de qualité
passe parfois aussi par une refonte des
cartes administratives la gestion des
services d'eau et d'assaainissement
l'illustre parfaitement la France compte
31000 services d'eau et
d'assaainissement 22000 gérés en régie
symbole d'une gestion communale de
proximité près de 92 % des régies
concerne un territoire de moins de 3500
habitants dans ce cas comme dans
d'autres proximité ne rime pas
nécessairement avec efficacité ou
qualité de l'action publique en l'espèce
tr trop de proximité peut parfois tuer
l'efficacité et la conduite d'une
réforme territoriale d'ampleur n'est pas
une tâche impossible l'état on a
d'ailleurs fait la preuve en procédant à
la refondte de la carte judiciaire
nous considérons que que cette réforme
est globalement positive même si sur
certains points elle n'a pas donné tous
les résultats escompté en ce qui
concerne en revanche le réseau des
sous-préfectures le ministère de
l'Intérieur se positionne entre le
statut quo et l'expérimentation or les
services publics de demain doivent être
orientés vers les besoins de demain qui
ne coïncide pas forcément avec le
maillage administratif du 20e siècle
voire du 19e siècle une refonte
expérimentale de la carte des
arrondissements d'Alsace et deoselle
vient d'entrer en vigueur le 1er janvier
2015 le ministre de l'Intérieur a
annoncé la poursuite de
l'expérimentation dans cinq régions la
cour y sera attentive les
recommandations de la la cour portant
sur le maillage territorial des services
publics ont aussi pour objectif une
réduction des inégalités d'accès lorsque
la répartition des moyens et des
infrastructures n'est pas assez lié aux
besoins le chapitre du rapport sur la
prise en charge des soins
palliatifs toujours très incomplète et
caractérisé par de fortes inégalités
territoriales en offre une
illustration dans des travaux récents
portant notamment sur les finances
locales ou sur la grande vitesse
ferroviaire la Cour a eu l'occasion
d'appeler les pouvoirs publics à adopter
une attitude plus réaliste plus
rationnelle y compris en ce qui concerne
les investissements publics le rapport
public annuel 2015 met en évidence de
nouvelles situations où les décisions
d'investissement ne sont pas
satisfaisantes du point de vue de la
gestion publique et tous ces exemples
rappellent qu'un investissement n'est
pas vertueux par principe il est
vertueux s les produits avec le souci de
l'utilité de l'efficacité de
l'efficience s'il améliore réellement le
service rendu et si les dépenses de
fonctionnement qu'il entraînent ont été
correctement anticipées la refonte du
circuit de paix des agents de l'État
offre un contreexemple calamiteux
d'investissement entre 2008 et 2013 346
millions d'euros ont été dépensés au
titre de ce programme pratiquement en
pure perte cet échec n'est pas rassurant
au regard des enjeux soulevés par la
modernisation des processus de paix et
la cour s'inquiète d'ailleurs des
difficultés récurrentes que rencontre
cont des grands projets informatiques
menés par l'État ce qui est vrai pour
l'action de l'État est également pour
l'action locale je cite fréquemment le
cas des deux gares construites à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres d'écart
sur la LGV Est TGV laoren et Meuse TGV
sans interconnexion avec le réseau de
transport régional le cas des aéroports
de Dol et de Dijon distant de moins de
50 km à peine et à bien des écarts
comparables leur bilan financier
choquant ce qui a mène la cour à
recommandé la fin du soutien public aux
deux
équipements sans pour autant être placé
au même niveau que les investissements
que je viens de mentionner d'autres
situations appellent la vigilance des
pouvoirs publics par exemple alors que
les contraintes budgétaires s'accentuent
chacquean anné davantage les offres
proposées en matière de transport public
urbain de voyageurs continuent de
s'étaufer sans toujours la coordination
ni les mutualisations euh des efforts
nécessaires autre exemple celui des
stations de ski des Pyrénées il est
souhaitable que les collectivités
territoriales acceptent de restructurer
les stations et de repenser dans un
certain nombre de situations leur modèle
économique en conclusion comme elle a
toujours fait la cour appelle les
pouvoirs publics à s'engager résolument
en faveur du redressement des comptes
publics et d'une action publique plus
exigeante plus rigoureuse mais surtout
plus efficace et plus efficiente c'est
possible et c'est selon nous nécessaire
nous essayons de le démontrer des
marches de manœuvre existent des
réformes d'ailleurs sont attendues par
nos concitoyens qui savent pertinemment
que la qualité des services public ne se
confond pas toujours avec l'augmentation
de la dépense publique je veux rappeler
en ce lieu l'article 14 de la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme et du
Citoyen tous les citoyens ont le droit
de constater par eux-mêmees ou par leurs
représentants vous-même la nécessité de
la contribution publique de la consentir
librement d'en suivre l'emploi le
entement à l'impôt et le fondement de
notre démocratie et c'est à vous
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
qu'il appartient bien évidemment de
convaincre nos concitoyens de la
nécessité de consentir à l'impôt pour
cela nulle meilleure méthode que
d'arrêter des priorités de prendre les
décisions qui en découlent de veiller à
la mise en œuvre effective de ces
décisions alors que trop souvent une
fois la loi votée ou la décision prise
le regard peut se détourner de
l'évaluation effective du résultat même
si je reconnais qu'ici au Sénat il
existe une culture de contrôle et
d'évaluation plus ancienne chacun dans
le rôle qui est le sien peut contribuer
aux réformes qui s'impos par son rapport
public annuel et plus généralement par
ses travaux la cour s'efforce pour sa
part à sa seule place de contribuer à ce
qu'une attention plus grande soit porté
au au résultats veillez à l'article 14
de notre déclaration 2700 89 s'est
accordé à l'avenir plus d'importance à
la performance à l'efficacité réelle de
l'action publ je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci le monsieur le Premier
Président Monsieur le Premier Président
le Sénat vous donne acte du dépôt du
rapport annuel de la Cour des comptes la
parole est maintenant à madame la
présidente de la commission des
finances vous avez la parole madame la
Présidente Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Premier Président de la Cour des
comptes mes chers collègues une fois par
an le contrôle des finances publiques
fait la Une de toute la presse écrite et
audiovisuelle ce grand moment
d'exposition médiatique c'est le dépôt
du rapport public annuel de la Cour des
comptes que nous enseigne l'intérêt
suscité par cette publication il montre
d'abord que la Cour des comptes atteint
le but qui lui est assigné par l'article
472 de la Constitution je cite par ces
rapports publics elle contribue à
l'information des citoyens j'y vois
ensuite une invitation pour nous
parlementaires et en particulier pour
les rapporteurs spéciaux des commissions
des finances à ne pas lâcher nos efforts
en matière de contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement nos concitoyens nous
attendent sur ce
terrain le contrôle tel qu'il est
effectué par la Cour des comptes n'a pas
la même finalité que le contrôle
parlementaire l'un contrôle le bon
emploi de l'argent public ou
l'efficience des politiques publiques
nous évaluons nous la pertinence des
choix politiques nos travaux sont donc
complémentaires et souvent convergents
l'insertion dans le rapport public
annuel Consac cré à l'opérateur national
de paye fait éch aux auditions sur ce
thème que notre commission a organisé en
mai dernier Philippe adnaau pourra
nourrir les travaux qu'il a engagé
depuis l'année dernière sur le maintien
des droits des étudiants boursiers des
développements du rapport sur
l'indispensable modernisation du réseau
des œuvres sociales et universitaires
enfin j'observe que dans sa réponse le
président de l'Agence française de lutte
contre le dopage indique qu'il a en
quelque sorte
répondu par avance à certaines
observations de la Cour des comptes en
engageant des réformes inspirées des
conclusions de la commission d'enquête
du Sénat sur la lutte contre le dopage
dont le président était notre collègue
Jean-François Himbert et le rapporteur
notre collègue Jean-Jacques LAAC ayant
rédigé l'année dernière un rapport
d'information dans lequel je rappelais
la nécessité de préserver le sous-préfet
comme porte d'entrée du réseau des
services de l'État j'ai lu avec
attention vos développements sur le
réseau des
sous-préfectures j'ai également bien
noté l'insertion consacrée au Centre de
gestion de la fonction publique
territoriale qui pourra constituer une
lecture utile dans certains
départements la Cour des comptes assiste
le Parlement dans le contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement et cette année
encore l'assistance que portera la Cour
des comptes au titre de l'article 582 de
l' organique relative au loi de finances
s'annonce très utile la commission des
finances a rendu publique hier son
programme de contrôle pour l'année 2015
et comme chaque année plusieurs
rapporteurs pourront s'appuyer appuyer
leurs travaux sur des enquête demandé à
la Cour des comptes Antoine Lefèvre a
présenté le mois dernier un rapport sur
la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
qu'il a préparé à partir d'une enquête
de la cour nous organiserons bientôt
deux auditions à partir d'enquête
remises par la Cour et qui donneront
lieu à des rapports d'information
d'Alain ouperte et Yannick bautrell sur
la filière bois et d'alberérique de
gofier philippe Dallier sur le recours
par l'État aux consultants extérieurs
plus tard dans l'année des enquêtes de
la Cour des comptes bénéficieront aux
travaux de Francis del latre sur le fond
CMU de Philippe adnaau sur l'autonomie
financière des universités ou encore de
François Marc sur le Crédit Immobilier
de France le rapporteur général tirera
également profit d'enquête sur la
fonction publique tandis que les travaux
du groupe de travail que nous venons de
constituer sur le logement en vue de
préparer les prochains débats budget
budgétaire n'est-ce pas monsieur le
rapporteur général seront complétés par
une enquête sur les aides personnelles
au logement qui sera remise à Philippe
daller d'ici la mi-juillet pour achever
cette énumération j'indique qu'en 2016
ce sont les travaux de marc Laménie sur
la journée défense et citoyeneté qui
seront éclairés par les résultats d'une
enquête réalisée par la Cour des comptes
si la Cour des comptes nous prête
assistance en réalisant des enquêtes à
notre demande n nous nourrissons nos
travaux des différentes publications
issues de la cour tout au long de
l'année nous avions en mai dernier
organisé des auditions consacrées à la
rénovation thermique des logements
privés en partant de constatation
présenté dans un référé constaté
consacré à la gestion de l'Agence
nationale de
l'habitat cette audition a pu enrichir
les travaux de notre rapporteur général
sur la réforme de l'ch pré à tau zéro
dans le projet de loi de finance pour
2015 notre rapporteur pour avis du
projet de loi sur la transition
énergétique jean-fran François Husson
s'y est aussi référé lorsqu'il nous a
présenté son analyse du nouveau fond de
garantie pour la rénovation énergétique
la commission des finances a également
organisé une audition pour suite à
donneré au référés relatifs à l'École
nationale supérieure des beauards qui
était particulièrement critique si
Didier Migot est l'une des personnalités
les plus fréquemment entendues chaque
année par la commission des finances
c'est parce que la Cour des comptes joue
un rôle croissant dans la gouvernance
des finances publiques nos rendez-vous
institutionnels sont de plus en plus
fréquent nos travaux désormais très
imbriqués en outre la Cour des comptes
devient aussi une actrice à part entière
du cycle budgétaire elle certifie les
comptes de l'État à travers le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques danst la
moitié des membres sont issus de la Cour
des comptes et à parité grâce à un
amendement du Sénat de notre collègue
gatolin il y a quelques temps
euh c'est qui en assure donc le la cour
des compte à sur le secrétariat de ce
Haut Conseil elle joue un rôle dans le
déclenchement du nouveau mécanisme de
correction automatique elle apprécie la
situation des finances publiques en
amont du débat d'orientation des
finances publiques et l'insertion
liminaire du rapport public annuel sur
les finances publiques constitue
généralement un avant-goût des
thématiques qui sont développées la Cour
des Comptes est une vigie exigeante en
matière de maîtrise des comptes public
et aller dans son rôle lorsqu'elle
insiste sur les risques entourant la
trajectoire des finances publiques
défini par le gouvernement ainsi que sur
la nécessité de renforcer la maîtrise
des dépenses publiques ces conseils sont
précieux et il est important pour la
crédibilité de notre pays dans la zone
euro que des voies indépendantes
s'expriment sur les finances publiques
pour autant je pense qu'il est
raisonnable dans le respect des règles
budgétaires européennes d'adapter le
rythme de réduction des déficits aux
évolutions de la conjoncture pour ne pas
risquer d'amplifier la crise et afin de
concilier consolidation budgétaire et
croissance conformément aux conclusions
du dernier G20 de brisban ce choix de
politique économique me semble le plus
opportun et le plus crédible dès lors
qu'il ne s'accompagne pas d'une remise
en cause de l'effort de maîtrise des
dépenses publiques tous les rapporteurs
spéciaux et pour avis le constate tous
les ministères le ressentent toutes les
données d'exécution le montrent les
dépenses de l'État sont désormais tenu
les économies sont tangibles les
dépenses nouvelles compensées par des
annulation ailleurs notre effort
structurel porte depuis 2014 presque
exclusivement sur les dépenses au total
je veux donc retenir la grande
convergence de nos préoccupations et la
priorité que nous accordons à la
maîtrise des dépenses public et au terme
de cette intervention je forme le vœux
que notre coopération dans les enceintes
institutionnelles comme dans nos
contacts informelles se poursuivent
cette année dans les mêmes excellents
termes que les années précédentes je
vous remercie
merci merci madame la
Présidente la parole est maintenant à
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires
sociales vous avez la parole monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Président
de la Cour des comptes madame la
présidente de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues je voudrais à mon tour saluer
le travail considérable dont témoigne le
rapport public annuel que vienent de
nous présenter monsieur le Premier
Président et en souligner le grand
intérêt une fois encore pour le
Parlement permettez plus spécifiquement
au président de la commission des
affaires sociales de se féliciter de la
contribution de la Cour des comptes que
la Cour des comptes apporte à travers de
multiples travaux à l'évaluation de
notre système de protection sociale son
implication croissante dans ce domaine
constitue le corelaire indispensable de
la responsabilité exercé par le
Parlement depuis l'instauration des lois
de financement de la sécurité sociale en
1996 responsabilité pleinement justifié
dès lors que les finances sociales
représentent je le rappelle près de la
moitié des comptes publics de notre pays
certes la situation des comptes sociaux
peut paraître relativement moins
dégradée que celle du budget de l'État
mais nous partageons le point de vue
exprimé à de nombreuses reprises par le
premier président de la cour des comptte
selon lequel il est profondément anormal
de financer par le déficit et
l'endettement des dépens courante de
prestation social il y va tout
simplement de la viabilité d'un modèle
social auquel nous savons tous nos
concitoyens sont légitimement
attachés s'agissant de l' examen
d'ensemble des finances publiques en
2014 la commission des affaires sociales
partage très largement les appréciations
portées par la cour comme la cour elle
considère que la révision des prévisions
liées à la dégradation de
l'environnement macro-économique a été
tardive dans les textes financiers de
fin d'année alors que le Parlement
aurait pu en être saisi dès l'été de
même alors que l'objectif national des
dépenses d'assurance mal dit le fameux
Onam a été revu à la baisse dans la loi
de finissement de financement
rectificatif de l'été aucune alerte n'a
été émise sur le dynamisme des dépenses
d'indemnité journalière ou de
médicaments notamment pour le traitement
d'hépatite C que nous avons constaté en
fin d'année nous partageons aussi
plusieurs interrogations de la cour sur
les perspectives de l'exécution 2015
sans doute l'évolution du prix du
pétrole et du cours de l'euro
fournit-elle à notre pays un ballon
d'oxygène bienvenu qui permettra
peut-être de tenir les prévisions de
croissance mais comme le soulligne le
rapport public annuel les prévisions
d'économie en dépens qui reposaient
principalement sur la non revalorisation
des prestations n'ont pas été revu à la
baisse malgré une inflation
prévisionnelle divisée par 2 nous nous
interrogeons plus fortement encore
sur les économies attendues des régimes
à gestion paritaire une édique et
retraite complémentaire en l'absence de
toute disposition concrète de la même
manière si le gouvernement a intégré les
moindres dépenses lié au report de la
mise en œuvre de la loi sur le
vieillissement quen sera-t-il pour le
décalage de la loi santé à laquelle
était conditionné une bonne part des 3
milillards 200 millions d'euros
d'économie dans le champ de dame c'est
pourquoi la commission des affaires
sociales rejoignant en cela les
préconisations de la cour souhaite
renforcer son contrôle sur l'exécution
des lois de financement plus que jamais
il lui semble que l'enjeu pour le
Parlement réside bien dans la réalité
des dépenses exécutées plus que dans les
économies virtuelle annoncé nous y
consacrerons plusieurs auditions le mois
prochain dès que seront connus les
premiers résultats de clôture des
comptes 2014 du régime général le
rapport public annuel 2015 traite
également plusieurs points particuliers
touchant au domaine social il
s'intéresse au dispositif du chômage
partiel la Cour avait souligné il y a 2
ans son impact limité alors que
l'Allemagne a su en faire un instrument
efficace de préservation de l'emploi en
période de ralentissement économique
elle appelle à juste titre à évaluer
l'efficacité des mesures incitatives
votées en 2013 par le Parlement en vue
de développer le nouveau dispositif
d'activité partielle dans le suivi de
ces recommandation la cour revient
également sur un sujet particulièrement
important et d'actualité à savoir
l'accès aux soins palliatifs c'est en
effet l'un des rares points de consensus
dans le débat sur la fin de vie que
d'assurer à tous ceux qui le souhaitent
l'arrêt des soins curatifs une prise en
charge adapté leur procurant la
meilleure qualité de vie possible la
Cour note que le plan de développement
des soins palliatifs a atteint ses
objectifs en terme de nombre d'équipes
et de nombre de lit mais elle soulligne
ce que nous constatons tous sur le
terrain que ces efforts sont encore
insuff
par rapport aux besoins insuffisance du
développement des réseaux participation
des professionnels en ville encore trop
faible malgré l'implication des
infirmières et importantes inégalité
territorial ce conjugue pour que l'offre
demeure très inférieur aux besoins des
besoins dont la Cour note que nous n'en
connaissons pas encore l'ampleur exact
faute d'études suffisamment précis en
fait c'est une véritable culture
palliative que manque notre pays au
regard notamment des pays
anglo-saxons la Cour préconise notamment
de mieux adapter les soins palliatifs
aux maladies chroniques d'offrir un
accompagnement aux familles et de
développer l'offre palliative dans les
épades ces recommandations parfois
anciennes se heurtent clairement à des
problèmes de financement j'espère que
nous pourrons avec la cour avec le
gouvernement
trouver des solutions à ces difficultés
au-delà des éléments figurants dans le
rapport qui nous est remis ce matin je
voudrais souligner l'ampleur des travaux
réalisés par la Cour dans le sens d'une
meilleure évaluation de nos politiques
sociales je pense bien entendu au
rapport annuel sur l'application des
lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale qui par son ampleur s'apparente
en quelque sorte à un second rapport
public annuel entièrement consacré à la
sécurité sociale je pense à la
certification des comptes du régime
général mais aussi aux nombreux rapports
thématiques ou référés qui constituent
pour nous une source extrêmement
précieuse en terme d'analyse documentée
et de proposition je mentionnerai par
exemple le très récent rapport sur les
régimes de retraite complémentaire que
la Cour est venue présenter le mois
dernier devant la mission d'évaluation
et contrôle de la sécurité sociale notre
mex il s'agissait là d'une première car
jusqu'à présent la cour n'avait pas eu
l'occasion d'effectuer une analyse
financière qui est préoccupe dans une
analyse d'ensemble de ces régimes pardon
à gestion paritaire dont la situation
financière est préoccupante et dont les
résultats sont pleinement intégrés au
compte public notifié aux instances
européennes c'est donc un enjeu très
important pour nos concitoyens et pour
nos finances publiques que la Cour nous
a permis de mieux appréhender enfin je
voudrais rappeler que la commission des
affaires sociales sollicite la cour
comme le lui permet l'article
l132-3-1 du Code des juridictions
financières pour des enquêtes sur des
sujets qui lui semblent mériter une
analyse indépendante et
approfondie la cour nous a ainsi rendu à
l'été 2014 un important rapport
dressant le bilan des relations établies
par le biais des conventions entre
l'assurance maladie et les différentes
professions libérales de santé cette
question est au cœur de l'équilibre
délicat entre une large couverture de
soins de santé par l'assurance
obligatoire et le maintien d'une
organisation libérale de la santé qui
caractérise notre système français cette
enquête a été pour notre commission
riche d'enseignement sur de très
nombreux points que je ne développerai
pas je citerai néanmoins l'une de ces
recommandations que nous partageons
visant à informer chaque année le
Parlement des objectifs et des résultats
de la politique
conventionnelle je souhaite également
mentionner le président Larcher en a
parlé l'enquête sur la situation des
maternités en France qui avait été
demandé par la président Annie David et
qui nous a été remise il y a quelques
semaines au-delà des échos
schématique et très souvent inexact qui
ont été donnés par la presse cette
enquête analyse de manière objective la
situation de ce secteur essentiel de
notre système
hospitalier les difficultés de
recrutement un financement inadapté une
certaine passivité face à des intigateur
de périnatalité insuffisant une
organisation manquant encore de
cohérence sont autant de constats qui
appellent aux yeux d' cour une politique
active des pouvoirs publics nous avons
au niveau de la commission d'affaires
sociales juger l'enjeu suffisamment
important pour en débattre en séance
publique avec le gouvernement sur la
base de votre enquête monsieur le
Président le 4 mars prochain ceci
m'amène pour conclure à me féliciter que
le rapport public annuel comporte sous
forme synthétique une analyse du suivi
des recommandations de la Cour cela nous
permet de mesurer les progrès accomplis
mais aussi les obstacles qui surviennent
ou les marges qui subsistent sur la voie
d'une gestion plus efficace de nos
politiques social et des financements
très importants qui leur sont consencrés
c'est un élément qui conforte le
concours que la Cour des comptes nous
apporte dans l'exercice de nos fonctions
législatives et de contrôle je ne doute
pas que ce concours demeurera
extrêmement utile dans les mois et les
années à venir à un moment où plus que
jamais notre pays doit redresser ses
comptes
publics
merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Président
nous en avons terminer avec la
présentation de ce rapport et je voulais
vous en remercier ainsi que monsieur le
rapporteur général et maintenant je vais
demander aux huissiers de bien vouloir
vous reconduire en vous remerciant voilà
vous venez de suivre le dépôt du rapport
de la Cour des comptes par le premier
président de la Cour des comptes Didier
Migot une tradition républicaine qui
permet également de rappeler le travail
conjoint qui peut exister entre le Sénat
et la Cour des comptes ne bougez pas on
retourne tout de suite dans l'hémicycle
pour suivre et bien la reprise des
débats sur le projet de loi transition
énergétique et croissance verte
souvenez-vous hier les sénateurs
examiner le titre premier sur les grands
objectifs énergétiques de la France
aujourd'hui il s'attaque à un sujet qui
est plus consensuel l'isolation des
bâtiments tout de suite on retourne dans
l'hémicycle pour la séance l'ordre du
jour appelle la suite de la discussion
du projet de loi adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée relatif à la
transition énergétique pour la
croissance verte dans la discussion des
articles nous sommes parvenus à
l'amendement numéro 28 rectifié au sein
de l'article 3 B je suis saisie de deux
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune 28 rectifié qui le
défend monsieur revet vous avez la
parole mon cher collègue je suis là mais
je suis ravi de vous voir mon présidente
ministre le cet amendement est simple il
vise à compéter l'article 3B en visant
par le texte en visant une performance
de 105 50 kWh par mètre carré et par an
classer le logement en partant des plus
gros consommateurs énergétiques est une
idée pertinente mais il faut en outre
viser une performance énergétique
possible après rénovation énergétique
150 K W par mère carré et par an doivent
être accessibles à condition de procéder
à des travaux
pertinents merci Monsieur revet
l'amendement numéro 588
rectifi madame l m vous avez la parole
oui madame la Présidente il est
exactement identique à celui de mon
collègue Charles
Revet donc comme défendu merci Madame l
mur avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur s'il vous plaît merci madame
la Présidente pas tout à fait identique
un tout petit peu moins un petit peu
moins sévère écoutez mes chers collèg
sur ces deux amendements la Commission
avait donné un avis défavorable moi j'ai
un petit peu peur
d'ailleurs de ce qui s'est passé hier
soir hier soir on a pris deux décisions
notamment obligeant à ce qu'un certain
nombre de mesures soit prises avant 2020
et d'autres on a rendu pardon
obligatoire le fait aussi qu'il faut
accélérer tous les logements qui ont un
propriétaire privé et un
locataire et s'ils veulent pas faire les
travaux madame la ministre il se passera
rien du tout il se passera rien du tout
il n'y a aucune sanction je dis ça parce
que c'est de mesures ce sont encore de
mesures un peu plus sévères et
contraignantes votre objectif est un
objectif
ambitieux nous sommes en train de mettre
là en ce moment des conditions encore
plus sévères madame la ministre ce qui
va marcher c'est pas le bâton c'est la
carotte tout va dépendre des moyens
financiers que vous allez mettre pour
inciter les Français à rénover leur
bâtiment vous mettez des contraintes
sans aucune sanction donc si demain les
propriétaires bailleurs privés ne
veulent pas faire des travaux avant 2020
vous avez rabassé de 2030 à 2020 et
alors qu'est-ce qui se passera rien rien
on aa encore plus de difficultés à
atteindre les 500000 logements
rénovés AB baisser le plafond de 2030 à
2020 même sort donc moi je veux bien que
on continue à avoir des mesures de plus
en plus contraignantes ces deux mesures
le sont et c'est la raison pour laquelle
mes chers collègues moi je vous suggère
de retirer l'amendement de ne pas les
mettre c'est pour ça que nous avons émis
un évidi favorable mais attention à ne
pas vouloir avoir un comportement plus
rénovateur thermique que moi tuumeur
mais prendre des décisions qui n'auront
aucune espèce d'effet et qui risque de
ne pas vous permettre madame la ministre
d'atteindre votre objectif c'est
l'inverse ouvrez complètement n'obligez
pas permettez à ceux qui veulent rénover
de le faire qu'il soi propriétaire
bailleur qu'il soit propriétaire
occupant mais ne mettez pas des freins
et des barrières supplémentaires vous
allez vous compliquer la tâche tout ça
pour dire je vous suggère mes chers
collègues de de les retirer ce sont deux
contraintes supplémentaires C qui sont
pas illogiques hein euh vous fixez la
mesure très forte on y arrivera pas vous
en êtes conscient c'est raison pour
lequelle je vous suggérais de
retirer merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame la ministre avis du gouvernement
s'il vous plaît oui merci madame la
Présidente je je vois que monsieur le
rapporteur revient sur l'amendement voté
hier moi je voudrais quand même rappeler
qu'on est dans une urgence climatique on
peut pas sur la scène internationale
dire qu'il y a une urgence climatique
par rapport au dérèglement climatiqu que
des centaines de millions de personnes
vont être menacé maintenant à l'échelle
planétaire et prévoir 10 ans pour faire
la transition énergétique
donc je pense que l'amendement qui a été
présenté hier par tous les groupes
d'ailleurs parce qu'il y avait un
amendement de l'UMP du groupe socialiste
du groupe écologiste du groupe
udi qui a ramené de 10 ans mais c'est
très long 10 ans c'est pas une
transition énergétique 10 ans à 5 ans le
fait de de faire des travaux franchement
ça me semble tout à fait raisonnable
alors vous avez raison à nous de faire
en sorte qu'il y ait l'accompagnement
technique l'accompagnement financier et
je crois que l'accompagnement technique
et financier il est là il faut s'en
saisir et il faut vraiment que que nous
rentrions dans la transition énergétique
parce que plus elle sera accélérée plus
les entreprise du bâtiment pourront
programmer des investissements et créer
les emplois qui vont avec et plus le
coût des travaux baissera si en effet
ces travaux restent marginaux ils vont
continuer à coûter cher plus ces travaux
vont être importants plus le fait de
doubler ses ses fenêtres d'isoler les
combles et d'ailleurs beaucoup de
régions de départements des communes
mettent déjà en place des financement
pour aider les particuliers à entrer
dans cette transition énergétique et à
faire les travaux parce que c'est du
gagnant gagnant c'est gagnant pour la
facture énergétique des des citoyens qui
habitent ses logements et c'est surtout
gagnant pour les entreprises qui
attendent vraiment avec impatience et si
on dit aux entreprises ben non on vous
donne 10 ans on donne 10 ans aux gens
pour faire les travaux c'est pas
crédible donc moi je me réjouis de
l'amendement qui a été voté hier 5 ans
c'est déjà très long 5 ans vous rend des
comptes le temps de prendre la décision
d'engager les travaux de réaliser les
travaux de payer de payer les les entre
ise c'est déjà très long là le crédit
d'impôt de la transition énergétique il
est fait pour cette année je ne sais pas
s'il sera reconduit l'année prochaine ça
c'est le Parlement qui qui en décidera
le gouvernement qui prendra des
arbitrages donc aujourd'hui le signal
que l'on donne aux familles c'est de
s'engager très rapidement dans la mise
en place de ces travaux en saisissant ce
crédit d'impôt qui allège je le rappelle
de 30 % la facture des travaux donc sur
l'amendement qui est présenté et qui va
aussi dans le bon sens moi je ne me vois
pas en tant que ministre chargé de
ologie m'opposer à des amendements qui
viennent de groupes politiques
différents et donc ça veut dire que de
quelque part ils ont aussi ils sonti
aussi en train de construire une une une
un modèle énergétique offensif et quand
je vois effectivement des amendements
qui viennent qui sont identiques et qui
viennent de groupes différents au Sénat
ma responsabilité politique c'est de les
écouter et de dire bah voilà s'il y a
des offensives supplémentaires par
rapport aussi aux difficultés
d'arbitrage interministériel des
pesanteurs des résistances des
bureaucraties diverses et variées qui
font que c'est toujours difficile
d'avancer et d'accompagner le changement
je me dois de soutenir ces amendements
maintenant est-ce qu'il faut aller
jusqu'à cette précision ce n'est pas
évident ce que je proposerais c'est
c'est de sousamender votre amendement en
disant en prenant acte effectivement de
la proposition de la performance
énergétique que vous proposez qui est
une performance énergétique exigeante
mais c'est pas moi qui vais être contre
puisque je suis pour la construction de
logement énergie positive je considère
que tous les nouveaux logements
notamment fait par les administrations
pour les les logements les les
constructions publiques doivent être des
logements énergie positive c'est tout de
suite ê tout de suite sur la haute
technologie pourquoi parce que les
entreprises du bâtiment si on est dans
l'entre deux elles vont se dire est-ce
que ça vaut le coup d'investir tout de
suite sur la performance énergétique des
bâtiments sur le choix des matériaux sur
l'efficacité énergétique des fenêtres et
cetera sur les récupérations de chaleur
bah il faut leur dire oui vous avez
intérêt à anticiper puisqueun jour ou
l'autre les normes seront de plus en
plus exigeantes en matière de de de
lutte de de performance énergétique des
bâtiments donc plus on sera dans les
entre-deux plus les entre-deux traînent
moins les investissements sont
performants et moins les entreprises
sont incitées à investir donc moi je
suis favorable à l'accélération de de la
transition énergétique et dès lors
qu'elle qu'elle est elle est en plus
proposé par des des par les sénateurs je
je soutiens ces amendements parce que ma
responsabilité chargé de l'écologie
c'est d'accompagner la transition
énergétique et d'accélérer la transition
énergétique et d'être en phase avec les
discours sur l'urgence climatique donc
j'ai met un avis favorable à ces
amendements en précisant peut-être que
euh que le le bien que que le cette
performance énergétique sera le plus
rapidement possi bien évidemment fixé
par par
décret madame la ministre j'ai bien pris
acte mais il faudrait rédiger donc le
sous-amendement si vous voulez que je le
fasse voter parce que là pour l'instant
il n'est pas facile à
rédiger alors explication de vote
monsieur revet oui merci madame la
présidente madame le ministre je crois
que nous sommes tous d'accord pour dire
que si l'on pouvait développer une
politique de
logement qui minimise la consommation
d'énergie
je crois qu'il faut le faire et dieuss
qu'il y a du travail quand on voit les
logements qui ont été construits les
locatifs il y a 50 ans il y a 60 ans où
sont des vrais passoirs et où il y a une
consommation d'énergie qui est
extrêmement importante donc délogement
un résultat positif on est tous d'accord
j'ai bien entendu ce que vous avez dit
d'ailleurs hier en terme de coût
comparés qui sont extrêmement importants
alors ceci étant je je vais peut-être
passer la main à Madame Lamur et retirer
mon amendement au profit du sien j'ai
bien
entendu j'ai bien entendu ce qu'a dit
monsieur le rapporteur et nous devons
pas être trop contraignant et je je
considère que celui qui a été déposé par
Madame Lamur est plus complet et donc je
retire mon amendement au profit du
sien pour explication de vote oui madame
la Présidente ça me permet de vous
indiquer que mon amendement est assorti
d'une condition qui est très importante
qui dit si le calcul économique le
permet c'est pour cette raison que je
pense que je peux vous inviter à
l'adopter donc vous proposez de ne pas
sous-amender monsieur le rapporteur oui
je propose de de conserver mon
amendement dans sa rédaction sans
sous-amender bon je vous remercie de
votre ente tous les deux parce que bien
sûr le meilleur des deux c'est celui
d'Élisabeth amur qui qui a au moins une
petite phrase mais vous êtes ce vous
faites vous êtes conscient de ce que
vous faites vous allez obliger les
propriétaires bailleurs privés à
dépenser plus
d'argent vous allez les obliger à
d'argent ça revient à ça mais si plus
vous avez des mesures contraignantes
techniquement pour mieux et plus
complètement isoler votre logement ça ne
concerne donc le propriétaire bailleur
qui a un locataire ou de trois donc
quand même un certain nombre de français
je dirais de classe moyenne cette mesure
va les obliger à dépenser plus d'argent
donc soyez bien conscient des
conséquences d'un tamendement mais entre
les deux je préfère bien sûr
l'amendement de de Madame ellisabeth
Lamur madame la ministre souhaitez-vous
sous-amender ou acceptez-vous un avis
favorable tel quel avis favorable merci
madame le ministre je vais donc mettre
au voix j'ai monsieur bien sûr de cessar
qui demande la parole et vous
l'avez j'ai du mal à comprendre votre
raisonnement monsieur le
rapporteur tout à l'heure vous
avez donné un avis un peu négatif sur
cet amendement en disant mais il y a
rien qui contraint les personnes à le
faire et donc vous moi j'avais compris
lorsque vous disiez cela un certain
regret qu'il y ait pas une obligation
pour le faire donc j'avais compris que
vous situez bien dans la
démarche d'une dynamique positive pour
la rénovation des bâtiments et là vous
prenez un argument inverse vous dites
vous savez ça va coûter cher même si
c'était plus tard ça coûterait cher à un
moment donné donc l'argument que vous
défendez maintenant n'est pas du tout
compatible avec les arguments que vous
avez défendu tout à l'heure tout à
l'heure on pourit comprendre vous pouvez
dire attention vous mettez des
contraintes les gens vont avoir du mal à
le faire donc là on peut on peut le
comprendre mais là vous dites ça va
coûter cher mais de toute façon ça va
coûter cher le problème c'est qu'est-ce
qui P quels sont les aides quelles sont
les différentes modalités mais de toute
façon il y aura un cout à court terme
mais il y aura des économies à long
terme c'est le principe donc là votre
argument à mon avis n'est pas cohérent
en tout cas avec l'explication plutôt
enfin sensé que vous aviez donné dans un
premier temps merci Monsieur de cessar
je n'ai plus de demande d'explication de
vote je n'envois pas je mets au voix cet
amendement donc
588 rectifié qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient l'amendement est
adopté je mets au voix l'article 3B
ainsi rédigé qui est pour pour mes chers
collègues qui est pour l'article 3B qui
est contre qui s'abstient l'article 3B
est adopté article additionnel après
l'article
3B un amendement 519 présenté par
Monsieur Dantec
oui on est encore un peu dans la
dynamique de hier soir et j'ai j'ai
encore un peu de mal à me recaler pour
par rapport au clivage politique
habituel de de cette assemblée puis que
j'ai bien entendu le le rapporteur
expliquer que le bâton ça ne marchait
pas et que seul la carotte comptait donc
l'esprit 68 soufflé ce matin sur
l'Assemblée sur les propos du rapporteur
néanmoins j'ai tendance à penser que la
carotte et le bâton vont un peu ensemble
et que c'est comme ça que ça ça marche
le mieux mais ici ça répond peut-être à
une partie justement des des objection
du du
rapporteur l'amendement qui vous est
proposé est un amendement qui dit à quel
moment est la contrainte je dirais donc
le le bâton et il y a un moment clé il y
a un moment clé pour faire la la
rénovation énergétique des des bâtiments
privés résidentiels c'est le moment de
la mutation parce que la mutation c'est
en plus un moment où le secteur bancaire
intervient notamment en terme de
pré-relais donc c'est vraiment s'il y a
un moment où l'on peut justement trouver
les financements mettre une obligation
légale c'est bien le moment de la a donc
l'amendement que je vous propose me
semble tout à fait compléter ce qu'on a
déjà voté y compris comme l'a dit madame
la ministre le fait d'avoir mis
l'obligation de rénovation pour le parc
locatif en en 2020 en proposant donc
qu'à partir de 2030 là c'est quand même
une date extrêmement raisonnable mais si
vous sousamendez en 2020 je vous suivrai
mais en tout cas qu'à partir de 2030 les
bâtiments privés résidentiels devront
faire l'objet d'une rénovation
énergétique à l'occasion d'une mutation
selon leur niveau de performance
énergétique et en est étant toujours
aussi modéré mais là aussi on peut en
discuter pour durcir le texte je vous
propose qu'on ait un calendrier
progressif d'application de cette
obligation en fonction de la performance
énergétique est aller jusqu'en 2050 ce
qui nous permet bien de tenir l'objectif
2050 qui est dans la loi donc il me
semble que c'est un amendement de de
complément du du dispositif existant et
extrêmement modéré dans sa mise en
application merci Monsieur Dantec avis
de la commission sur cet amendement
monsieur le rapporteur
alors mes chers collègues c'est une
obligation supplémentaire elle est pas
bénine celle-là elle est pas
bénine vous êtes dans une situation où
vous devez vendre pour des raisons
personnelles vous êtes au chômage vous
alleer en maison de retraite donc le
coupprê tombe dès que l'on vend on doit
obligatoirement faire des travaux de
rénovation c'est bien ça que ça revient
on est bien d'accord non mais vous êtes
dans votre logique vous êtes dans votre
logique complète mais liberté où vas-tu
où vas-tu c'est fini c'est
fini comment c'est la loi la loi c'est
quand même une liberté en France on fait
ce qu'on veut de son logement faut pas
queil y ait une mesure législative qui
fait que demain le Français soit
condamné à vendre lorsqu'il n'a pas
notamment les moyens de faire un certain
nombre de travaux donc bien sûr vot la
commission donn un avis défavorable
mais cette inflation d'obligation suppl
aire vous êtes dans une logique totale
avec vous-même je ne suis pas surpris
que vous déposiez cet amendement qui est
de mon point de vue un amendement
liberticide merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame la ministre avis du
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
non c'est vrai que c'est c'est un débat
quand même intéressant parce que vous
disiez hier monsieur le rapporteur que
l'Allemagne réussissait à faire 720000
logements en en travaux d'isolation
c'est parce qu'il y a des règles très
cont trignante en Allemagne c'est-à-dire
effectivement que la rénovation des
logements est obligatoire au moment des
mutations c'est depuis très longtemps
l'Allemagne a fait ce pari pour donner
un signal fort et comme vous le disiez
d'ailleurs très justement tout à l'heure
il y a pas de contrainte dans le texte
ce qu'il faut c'est que la société toute
entière s'engage dans cette transition
énergétique et qu'on considère que les
travaux d'isolation sur les logements
constituent une chance une chance pour
créer des activités une chance pour la
croissance verte une chance pour que les
entreprises du bâtiment les artisans du
travail une chance pour que les gens
n'hésitent plus deuxièmement l'objectif
est commandme très lointain c'est 2030
ça veut dire et c'est relié avec
l'amendement que vous venez d'adopter
que aujourd'hui les gens vont se dire
bon ben de toute façon on a jusqu'en
2030 bah cette année on va faire les
doubles vitrages année prochaine on fera
les combles l'année suivante on fera
l'isolation des façades et cetera et de
toute façon ça va valoriser leurs bien
dans quelques années un logement qui ne
sera pas bien isolé sera un logement qui
aura perdu beaucoup de sa valeur et donc
c'est une façon aussi d'aider les
propriétaires à faire en sorte de
valoriser leurs biens de le vendre dans
de meilleures conditions parce que même
aujourd'hui ces obligation n'existe pas
regardez la performance énergétique
l'affichage de la performance
énergétique dans les documents notariés
est obligatoire et les gens commencent à
faire de plus en plus attention parce
qu'ils regardent maintenant les factures
d'énergie qu'ils sont obligés de payer
tous les trimestrees et il voit bien que
l'investissement dans l'isolation
énergétique est tout à fait importante
et et c'est d'autant plus crucial
d'accélérer le mouvement que les
collectivités territoriales vous êtes
des élus des territoires et vous voyez
bien les efforts considérables que font
les collectivités pour implanter des des
lieux de d'information sur les travaux
d'économie d'énergie le le les efforts
que font les artisans pour se former
pour être au niveau des travaux
d'isolation d'énergie si on accompagne
ce mouvement à ce moment-là en effet on
va déclencher des les acteurs
économiques pour pour qu'ils
investissent et les particuliers pour
qu'ils sortent leurs économies et que
leurs économies dans les travaux
d'isolation d'énergie sont parfaitement
bien placés puisque ça revalorise leur
patrimoine immobilier qui donc sera
vendu dans de meilleures conditions donc
à partir du moment où si vous le
permettez monsieur le rapporteur
contrairement à ce que vous dites il n'y
a pas de contrainte c'est un signal fort
c'est on est dans une logique où il faut
que les gens aient envie de s'engager
dans cette transition sans qu'on les
menace ou quoi que ce soit s'ils ont pas
les moyens financiers ils vont pas les
faire mais l'idée c'est qu'il se
saisissent très rapidement du crédit
d'impôt des prêt à tau zéro des des
sociétés de tiers financement et de
faire en sorte que du coup puisqu'il y
aura beaucoup de commandes que les prix
des travaux d'isolation puissent baisser
plus il y en aura plus les prix vont
baisser plus ça va être performant et
plus nous réussirons à baisser les
consommations énergétiques et donc on a
du gagnant gagnant pour les citoyens qui
vont faire des économies d'énergie
gagnant pour les territoires qui qui
vont créer des emplois dans les filières
du bâtiment et gagnant pour la planète
avec la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et donc l'urgence climatique
doit s'accompagner aussi de
l'accélération d'une transition
énergétique et et c'est de cette façon
là je crois qu'on sera le plus efficace
en terme de création d'activité et
d'emploi donc le gouvernement ém un avis
favorable à cet amendement merci Madame
la Ministre madame Lindman pour
explication de vote vous avez la parole
ma cher collègue oui on voit bien dans
cette affaire qu'il faut trouver les
outils qui son nécessaire pour atteindre
l'objectif là on vote un objectif 2030
ça donne un certain temps mais je
voudrais bien signaler au pouvoir public
et je pense que la ministre en est
consciente que prendre une telle
décision suppose qu'on crée de nouveaux
outils pour répondre à ça pourquoi parce
que quand je prends un exemple une
personne âgée même si elle a fait un
certain nombre de travaux réguliers
parce qu'elle en avait les moyens déjà
ou même qu'elle a fait appel à tiers
financeur je je je j'insiste je je ferai
d'ailleurs un amendement pour qu'être
sûr que dans les plateformes
énergétiques on aille aux gens et on
n'attende pas que les gens viennent
parce que vous avez toute une série de
personnes qui à partir de 70 ans ou
autres ne ne savent même pas ont peur
que ce soit trop cher et cetera donc on
a d'abord ce travail là deuxè travail
quand vous êtes à la mutation vous êtes
pas aux normes on vous prête plus à la
banque quand vous avez 77 ans ou 80 ans
on vous prête plus et les sociétés de
tiersfanceurs ne marcheront pas donc il
faut trouver un système qui soit de prêt
qui permette que au moment de la revente
on déduise l'argent qu'on a mis en
investissement et donc c'est là il y a
tout un montage financier technique
juridique à créer pour avoir un outil
spécifique qui au moment de la mutation
permet à celui qui n'a pas d'argent à
avancer de faire les travaux et de
prendre sur le prix qui va être déduire
du prix pour l'heure ces outils à mon
avis n'existent pas ou que très rarement
mais pour ant comme on est à l'horizon
de 2030 et Ben se fixer des objectifs
c'est aussi se fixer l'obligation de
trouver les moyens c'est toujours le
même débat je rappelle qu'on a eu
pendant des lustres ce débat sur le
dallo hein fallait-il faire le droit
opposable tant qu'on savait pas comment
logerait tout le monde ou fallait-il
faire le droit oposable pour s'imposer
de loger tout le monde
manifestement mettre l'obligation n'est
pas toujours mettre les moyens j'espère
en tout cas Madame le Ministre que la
nation mettra les moyens pour que les
propositions de nos collègues d'antc
puisse rentrer dans les faits sans que
ce soit une pénalité pour les plus
faibles merci madame linman monsieur DC
pour explication de VCT
oui je je rejoins complètement le le
propos de Marie Noël linman et on sait
bien qu'on a un outil financier à à
préciser et qui doit être à mon avis
opérationnel bien avant 2030 parce qu'il
va servir dans d'autres d'entre domaines
et que cette facilité de d'accès au
crédit notamment par le Pier
fininancement est un point clé pour une
loi efficiente je je remercie le
rapporteur l' dit spatski c'est encore
le matin mais là de bien remettre la
droite à droite et la gauche à gauche
parce que son discours d'abord je pense
que le terme liberticide chers collègues
faut qu'on le garde pour un certain
nombre de situations dans le monde tel
qu'il est gardons-le pour des situations
qui le nécessitent néanmoins c'est un
vrai discours libéraliste qu'a tenu le
le rapporteur et il est clair
aujourd'hui que l'état de la planète
c'est le libéralisme c'est l'incapacité
effectivement à mettre de la régulation
et de penser que spontanément uniquement
par la carotte par l'incitation les
choses marchent et on retrouve une
trajectoire 2 degrés ça n'est pas vrai
ça n'est pas vrai ça n'existe pas s'il
n'y a pas des règles et madame la
ministre a rappelé que l'Allemagne qui
qui sert parfois même au rapporteur
d'exemple sur la question de la
réhabilitation et la rénovation du parc
de logement le faisait c'est comme ça
qu'elle a atteint ses objectifs en plus
je pense qu'il y a une vraie cohérence
avec ce qu'on a voté hier c'est on a
donné un premier signal 2020 sur la
rénovation du parc privé locatif là on
donne un signal 2030 pour un certain
nombre d'entreprises ça veut dire qu'il
y a un vrai schéma cohérent d'engagement
de création de filière de création de
formation et donc on est bien étape par
étape et on crée de la cohérence dans
dans la loi et enfin en terme de liberté
mais sans utiliser des mots trop forts
je rappellerai quand même que ces
logements qui sont des passoirs
thermiques vont effectivement de plus en
plus connaître une décôte ça c'est
certain c'est-à-dire que ce sont les
logements qui seront achetables par les
plus modestes et ça veut dire que les
plus modestes si on ne met pas une
obligation se retrouveront avec des
logements qui seront des passoirs soit
ils ne pourront pas se chauffer soit ils
se retrouveront en situation de
précarité financière énergétique et
d'endettement donc c'est une mesure tout
à fait raisonnable et rationnel et je
crois que nous pourrions la voter tous
ensemble en écoutant bien ce qu'a dit
Marie Noë linman sur le fait qu'il y a
des accompagnements bancaires encore à
trouver mais on a le temps pour
cela merci Monsieur Dantec monsieur
Chassin pour explication de vote
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers
collègues je voulais effectivement
attirer l'attention sur ce que dit
Madame
litman à partir d'un certain âge c'est
plus possible d'avoir de
crédit et de plus je connais en tout cas
dans mon département des agriculteurs
qui sont retraités avec 700 € de
retraite par mois ou des
artisans qui se chauffent au bois parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas se chauffer à
d'autres énergies et qui n'ont pas les
moyens
de de rénover leur bâtiment euh de plus
certains vont effectivement aller en
épad c'est ce qu'a dit le rapporteur et
euh s'ils ne peuvent pas payer la le
prix de l'Pad ils seront euh obligés de
donc le département maisieur viendra en
aide mais il y aura une il y aura une
vente du du
du bien et s'il y a une vente du bien ce
bien ne pourra pas se vendre puisqu'il
sera pas rénové donc dans l'article il y
a bien il y a bien devront faire l'objet
d'une rénovation énergétique alors
madame la ministre vous avez indiqué que
effectivement c'était très
bien pour l'artisanat c'était très bien
au niveau économique
et c'est ce qu'il faut inciter à faire
puisque le gros enjeu de de de la
transition énergétique c'est l'isolation
des bâtiments ça on est d'accord mais on
ne peut
pas indiquer que c'est absolument
obligatoire quand les gens n'ont pas les
moyens de le faire il faut les inciter
mais il n'est pas possible de les
obliger merci merci Monsieur Jassin
monsieur de cessar pour explication de
vote monsieur le rapporteur je vais
encore faire des remarques sur vos
observations mais sachez qu'il n'y a
rien de personnel hein donc mais c'est
simplement par rapport aux options que
vous défendez c'est en 2030 monsieur le
rapporteur et vous-même vous avez donné
les conditions vous avez dit il y a rien
de
contraignant donc la question est posée
il y a rien de contraignant au début
j'ai trouvé ça très intéressant votre
analyse et là il y a quelque chose de
contraignant en
2030 donc il y a quand même le temps de
s'y préparer sur les moyens à mettre en
œuvre sur les crédits à apporter sur
toutes les modulations techniques donc
la question qui est posée est-ce que
votre discours du départ c'était
simplement bon euh le discours de bonne
intention ou est-ce qu'il y a vraiment
une volonté de mettre en œuvre parce que
j'avais compris que dans cet hémicycle
et même à l'Assemblée nationale gauche
et droite on avait bien sûr des débats
sur le nucléaire j'y reviendrai pas j'ai
raté euh la bonne discussion d'hier
mais sur la rénovation thermique on
était tous d'accord mais oui mais les
amis si si vous dites ça coûte cher faut
pas le faire de toute façon ça va coûter
cher au début à court terme ça coûtera
pas cher sur 30 ans 40 ans 50 ans parce
qu'il y aura des économies mais il y a
bien un moment il faudra avancer
l'argent mais si vous reculez devant
l'obstacle et bien on le fera jamais
donc c'est ça un discours d'intention
c'est dire il faut bien le faire mais
attention à la moindre difficulté stop
on s'arrête ce n'est plus possible il
faut quand même bien qu'on mette des
conditions faut qu' met justement alors
ce n'est pas liberticide monsieur le
rapporteur les gens ont la possibilité
de le faire avant ils ont la possibilité
de s'organiser d'ici 2030 ils ont la
possibilité d'engager les travaux avant
la mutation mais si vous mettez pas un
point enfin un objectif bien ça se fera
jamais et c'est ce qu'on appelle un
discours de bonne intention sans les
actes de mise en œuvre monsieur le
rapporteur c'est pas simplement madame
la ministre a décrit tous les avantages
je vais en dire en donner deux autres
nous avons ensemble fait une mission sur
l'électricité et on a tous la volonté
d'une indépendance énergétique et bien
moins il y aura de consommation plus il
y aura d'indépendance énergétique
monsieur le rapporteur on a tous vu la
difficulté qu'il y avait à gérer les
écarts de consommation et bien plus il y
aura de la rénovation thermique qui sera
mise en en place rapidement plus on
réduira les car parce que la révolution
enfin la rénovation thermique que vous
dont vous avez que vous avez des
difficultés à mettre en place elle
conduira à des écarts très importants de
consommation parce que c'est au même
moment qu'on consomme dans l'année et
par jour et au niveau horaire ce qui
veut dire qu'on va construire des
centrales thermiques ça veut dire qu'il
y a bien quelqu'un qui va payer donc on
va payer plus cher l'électricité l'État
sera obligé de payer donc là ce que vous
dites c'est cher c'est un invest ement
qui est cher c'est économique à long
terme et en plus ce que vous mettez pas
en place maintenant parce que c'est cher
pour le particulier ça sera cher pour
l'État ou cher pour les entreprises et
donc ça reviendra à être cher pour le
consommateur donc c'est absolument pas
une économie que vous faites merci
Monsieur deessard Madame lettard pour
explication de
vote mer si madame la présidente madame
la ministre chers collègues je ne vais
pas répéter ce que sur tous les banques
chacun a pu exprimer largement on est
tous d'accord sur le fait que la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments et de
l'habitat privé ancien est une nécessité
et un des éléments qui permettra
d'atteindre tous les objectifs que nous
visons collectivement sauf c'est vrai
Renand DC on ne peut partager que les
objectifs qui sont dans l'amendement que
que vous portez mais Marino linman l'a
dit par expérience on le sait tous quand
on est élu local qui sont les ménages
qui ont le plus de difficult
à justement accompagner la rénovation
thermique de leur logement qui sont les
ménages propriétaires occupants qui sont
en surendettement liés à des
consommations d'énergie trop élevé parce
qu'ils sont dans de l'habitat dégradé ce
sont les ménages les plus modestes ce
sont donc ceux qui auront les pires
difficultés du monde jour ils voudront
céder leurs logement ou faire les
travaux à avoir la
solvabilisation alors aujourd'hui une
chose se pose on le sait le programme
Habiter mieux qu'est-ce que c'est le
programme habit est mieux ce sont les
outils mis en place par l'ANA pour faire
en sorte que tous ces petits
propriétaires occupants qui sont des
retraités qui sont des gens qui vivent
tant dans la ruralité que dans
l'urbanité et dont la vocation sont
vraiment enfin en tout cas ces outils
habités mieux sont faits pour
accompagner cette solvabilisation
aujourd'hui on sait qu'on arrive au bout
du dispositif et qu'il y a plus les
moyens d'accord donc aujourd'hui se pose
le problème du financement de la
solvabilisation des ménages modestes
voire très modestes qui sont ceux qui
occupent ces patrimoines donc le
problème il est bien lié aux modalités
d'accompagnement de l'objectif donc si
vous le voulez bien moi je proposerai
bien à Madame la Ministre à notre
rapporteur mais surtout à monsieur
dantet qui est l'auteur de l'amendement
et ben peut-être de sous-amender s'il le
veut bien l'amendement disant sous
réserve des outils financiers qui
permettront d'atteindre cet
objectif tout simplement tout simplement
parce que sinon comme l'a dit Marie Noël
à juste titre imaginez la personne
retraitée propriétaire de sa petite
maison qui a besoin de partir en maison
de retraite parce qu'elle est atteinte
d'une maladie neurodégénérative elle
doit vendre son logement elle a une
toute petite retraite elle a pas les
moyens de faire les travaux elle n'a pas
le droit de vendre son logement donc on
voit bien qu'il y a des limites à cet
exercice et ces limites vont toucher les
ménages les plus modestes ceux qu'on
doit accompagner ceux qui sont pénalisés
donc vraiment 100 % d'accord sur
l'objectif et moi je vote cet amendement
si Monsieur dantech accepte de le
modifier de le sous-amender pour mettre
cette garantie sur le le financement ça
reviendra dans le débat à plusieurs
reprises car tout ce qui accompagne ces
ambitions qui sont vertueuses c'est bien
ça doit être bien sûr mesuré à à l'ône
des personnes les plus fragiles on sait
que les objectifs et les ambitions en
matière environnementale creusent le
fossé entre ceux qui sont en capacité
d'accompagner cette évolution et ceux
qui ne le sont pas on ne doit jamais
perdre de vue que tout ce qui touche à
la solidarité et à l'environnement à
l'écologie doivent être pensé
collectivement doivent être pensé de
façon cohérente parce que si on ne crée
pas les éléments et les outils qui vont
avec on va créer un vrai fossé entre
ceux qui ont les moyens d'accompagner la
transition énergétique et ceux qui ne
l'ont pas merci Madame l'état madame
hervioot pour explication de vote oui
merci madame la
Présidente à ce moment du débat je
voudrais aussi parler des gens qui n'ont
pas beaucoup de revenus et qui sont les
locataires ça touche à la fois bien sûr
cet amendement mais les deux amendements
précédents si vous êtes élu dans dans
une commune si vous faites partie du
CCAS vous avez pu tous voir que quand on
dit que ça coûte cher ça coûte cher
peut-être au propriétaire je veux bien
mais ça coûte cher surtout au locataire
et tous ces appartements ou ces maisons
surtout dans les zones rurales qui sont
des maisons rénovées ou de de briqu et
de broc souvent qui sont des vrais
passoirs à chaleur sont souvent chauffés
au avec des des radiateurs un peu style
grille peint et les les l'argent qui est
mis dedans par les les locataires c'est
vraiment des sommes astronomiques
parfois pour eux pour leur revenus moyen
parce que plus le logement loué est
dévalorisé parce que pas mis en
rénovation plus le coût du chauffage le
coût de l'électricité est important donc
je crois que quand on dit que ça coûte
cher ça coûte cher d'abord aux aux gens
qui louent ces logements et comme
souvent ils ne peuvent pas pas faire
face à ce qu'ils doivent à l'électricité
et bien ce sont ensuite les CCAS qui par
des accords prennent le relais donc ça
coûte cher aussi à la collectivité et
d'une autre manière donc je crois que
quand on parle bien sûr des
propriétaires qui ne sont pas des gens
qui roulent sur l'or il faut prendre des
précautions mais globalement dans tous
ces cas-là ce sont quand même les gens
qui ne sont pas propriétaires qui sont
les premiers à subir le contrecût de la
non mise norme et de la non réffe de ces
bâtiments merci madame hervie monsieur
Cardou pour explication de
vote merci madame la présidente Madame
le Ministre pardonnez-moi d'intervenir
j'avais pas prévu mais je crois que nous
sommes dans un débat pour ma part que je
considère comme assez surréaliste je je
suis tout à fait des conclusions de
notre rapporteur nous sommes dans une
démarche libérale ce que bien sûr n'a
pas souhaité suivre monsieur Dantec mais
quand même quand quand même nous nous
sommes en train nous sommes déjà dans
une économie administrée allonsous
allons-nous rentrer dans une vie et dans
les choix des Français qui vont être
administrés considérons-nous comme
normal que dans quelques années si on
suit une telle dérive chacun d'entre
nous doiv avoir son petit livret dans sa
vie individuelle de tous les jours pour
savoir ce qu'il a le droit ou ce qu'il a
le droit de ne pas faire donc imposer de
tel chose et j'y reviendrai sur le délai
à à l'occasion d'un texte sur sur
l'énergie je trouve assez ça surréalisme
enfin je suis peut-être à côté de la
plaque mais je voulais le dire la
deuxième chose c'est qu'on est en train
de légiférer pour 2030 2030 c'est dans
15 ans c'est presque une génération
avons-nous le droit pouvons-nous nous
arroger le droit de prendre telle
décision pour le léguer aux générations
futures nous allons déjà leur léguer euh
collectivement collectivement des
déficits budgétaires considérables qu'on
a chiffré de manière individuelle par
français qui seront extrêmement lourde
allons-nous ajouter à ces charges
collectives que le gouvernement en place
à l'époque devra bien assumer des
charges individuelles résultant de tel
texte moi j'avoue que je suis assez
sidéré qu'on puisse imaginer de teles
choses et la troisième élément que je
voulais souligner madame le ministre
c'est que bien entendu euh ces travaux
euh en 2030 euh seront réalisés par des
entreprises et des artisans mais
croyez-vous qu'actuellement les artisans
dans l'état de de de besoin de travail
devant lequel ils sont seront sensibles
à un argument en disant on vous donnera
du travail en 2030 moi je pense qu'on
pourrait plutôt considérer que les
artisans actuellement sont confrontés à
des difficultés importantes et c'est
maintenant qu'il faut leur apporter des
solutions c'est pas en 2030 donc voilà
j'ai simplement voulu exprimer ce que je
ressentais à l'occasion de ce débat et
bien évidemment vous avez compris que je
ne voterai absolument pas cet amendement
merci Monsieur Cardou monsieur Dallier
pour explication de
vote merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre mes chers collègues moi je
ne me placerai pas sur le terrain des
des libertés individuel je crois que
l'objectif nous le partageons tous
seulement je ne veux plus voter
d'amendements ni de texes qui promettent
à terme Mons et merveilles sans savoir
si nous avons la capacité de le faire et
comment nous allons le faire nous sommes
en 2015 souvenez-vous et chers collègues
qu'en 2005 il y a 10 ans nous avons voté
à l'unanimité je crois ici au Sénat à
l'Assemblée nationale le texte la
fameuse loi handicap et qu'est-ce que et
à mon avis on l'a fait j'en nai pas
exactement le souvenir mais sans
évaluation des coûts pour les
collectivités locales et on a vendu à
nos concitoyens que nous allions mettre
à niveau tous les bâtiments publics dans
ma commune de 22000 habitants quand on a
fait le calcul c'était 15 millions
d'euros à trouver on a été incapable de
le faire même si nous avons fait des
choses avec de la bonne volonté mais on
a été incapable de le faire et 10 ans
plus tard c'est rendez-vous devant les
Français et les parlementaires sont
obligés de leur expliquer bah écoutez on
est bien désolé mais encore une fois on
avait voté une loi généreuse mais on
n'est pas capable on n pas été capable
de la mettre en œuvre le dallo est-ce
que ce n'est pas un peu aussi la même
chose bien évidemment qu'il faut un toit
pour chacun pour chaque famille on a
voté le DALO en sachant toutes les
difficultés qu'on aurait oui c'est nous
madame linman vous avez raison mais 2005
c'était nous le dalallo c'était nous je
ne dis pas le contraire mais je pense
que que ça soit la loi handicap ou le
DALO je pense qu'on l'a tous voté et
aujourd'hui quelques années plus tard on
est confronté à la réalité et on n'est
pas capable de mettre en œuvre dans les
zones non tendues il y a pas de problème
mais dans les zones tendues on aboutit à
des situations complètement absurdes les
gens vont dans le tribunal administratif
font condamner l'état condamnation qui
ne signifie rien on prend dans une poche
de l'État pour mettre dans l'autre quel
que croyez-vous que les Français en
pensent c'est vraiment ça la question
aujourd'hui alors bien évidemment que je
partage l'objectif mais voter des
amendements ou des ou des textes qui
effectivement fixent de grandes
ambitions sans nous dire comment nous
allons les atteindre moi je ne peux plus
le
faire merci Monsieur
Dalier monsieur gréiller pour
explication de vote s'il vous plaît
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues je je complète
le propos de mes deux collègues à
l'instant l'idée est bonne mais mesurons
les conséquences de cette
idée moi je voudrais la prolonger un
instant C et ceux qui aont pas la
capacité effectivement de faire ces
travaux ça va se résumer à des friches
urbaines des friches rurales tout
simplement alors qu'on est dans un pays
où il y a de plus en plus de personnes
qui sont mal loger donc effectivement
l'idée mais c'est pas assez précis pour
pouvoir effectivement définir arrêter
2030 moi je peux pas voter effectivement
un amendement de cette sorte qui va
avoir des conséquences terribles qu'on
n' pas forcément mesuré c'est une bonne
idée mais ça reste au stade de la bonne
idée donc je peux pas le
voter merci Monsieur grimier monsieur le
squarnc s'il vous plaît pour explication
de
vote merci madame la présidente madame
ministre collègue je partage beaucoup de
de points de vue exprimés notamment ce
qui été exprimé par les vert pour ce qui
est des objectifs mais surtout par
Valérie lettard qui a soulevé tout de
même la question des
moyens et ce qu'a dit aussi collègue
Dalier par rapport au fait qu'on fasse
des promesses et qu'on les tienne pas
politiquement c'est dangereux je pense
que si nous
pouvons réussir c'est parce qu'on va
prendre des engagements FA mais clair
sinon on va pas on va pas entraîner les
gens dans l'enthousiasme il faut de
l'enthousiasme à cette histoire nous
sommes à un moment de grande crise où il
faut prendre des grands objectifs mais
dégager les moyens et on peut parce que
ça va créer beaucoup d'emplois si on y
va tous si on y croit je pense qu'on est
capable de faire une grande
œuvre question du logement dans la
création des nouveaux logements de
qualité mais il
la rénovation des anciens logements qui
qui est plus difficile mais donc si
l'état bien sûr est garant si ensemble
tous ensemble nous élaborons un document
précis et qui donne des garanties qui
donne un peu de desespoir aux gens car
aujourd'hui non seulement la situation
difficile mais nous sommes tous en panne
de donner de l'espoir aux gens c'est
quand même très très grave non seulement
ils vivent mal mais on n'est pas capable
d'apporter de l'espoir alors ici avec ce
projet là peut-être qu'on peut apporter
un peu d'espoir alors mettons-y prenons
les engagements soyons fermes soyons
clair mais je pense qu'il faut y aller
c'est une grande
affaire merci Monsieur monsieur danési
pour explication de vote
cet amendement selon moi heurte tout
simplement la réalité n'est-ce pas du du
quotidien en effet en plus des personnes
âgées déjà cité par notre collègue
madame lineman et ben il y aura
également les
héritiers qui auront du mal à se mettre
d'accord sur les modalités de
financement de la rénovation du logement
ou de la maison et puis il y aura parce
qu'ils sont nombreux nous le savons les
divorcés qui ne s'entendent plus sur
tout enfin généralement il s'entendent
même plus sur rien du tout d'ailleurs et
qui n'auront certainement
euh pas la possibilité de se mettre
d'accord sur les conditions de
financement d'un logement qui sera vendu
par la la suite n'est-ce pas ça c'est la
réalité du terrain et donc il y aura
chaque année des dizaines et des
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui à
partir de
2030 ne pourront pas appliquer la loi et
donc cette obligation me paraît inutile
euh pour une raison bien simple madame
le ministre l'a fort bien dit
euh le marché de l'immobilier euh et
bien il il va se traduire par des décôes
très fortes très
élevées pour toutes les logements qui ne
seront pas euh
effectivement mise au
normes en matière en matière d'isolation
donc pourquoi vouloir obliger les gens à
faire quelque chose qu' ne sont pas en
mesure de faire alors que tout
simplement il y aura derrière il y aura
tout naturellement la sanction du
marché et puis c'est ça tout simplement
le simple bon
sens et par conséquent je ne voterai pas
cet amendement merci monsieur danési je
n'ai plus de demande d'exlication de
vote si monsieur le rapporteur je vous
en prie ah Monsieur courte aussi oui je
voudrais bon saisir éventuellement la
suggestion si monsieur dantac est
d'accord de Valérie
lettard donc à
minima atténuer l'amendement de Monsieur
DC avec la suggestion économique que
propose Valérie lettard et on pourrait
prendre exactement les mêmes termes de
l'amendement précédent d'éliisabeth
Lamur on pourrait mettre faut que vous
soyez d'accord bien sûr à partir de 2030
les bâtiments privés résidentiels
devront faire l'objet d'une rénovation
énergétique à l'occasion d'une mutation
virgule selon leur niveau de performance
énergétique et si le calcul économique
le permet je reprends mot pour mot donc
ça çau ça ne change rien au reste j'ai
bien compris que le reste avait un
ère de repousser à un décret qui sera
pris par le gouvernement et qui laisse
un lapse de temps quand même puisque
j'ai bien noté que votre mesure était
pour
2030 ça ça atténuerait la brutalité et
quand Valérie léard a fait cette
proposition elle a parlé bien sûr des
notamment des personnes âgées ceux qui
risquaient de partir mais il y a pas que
ces personnesl une personne qui est
mutée professionnellement si elle est
obligée de vendre en urgence elle sera
pénalisé une personne au chômage il
arrive que des gens au chômage soitent
aussi obligés de vendre leurs biens en
urgence donc il y a plein de cas de
figure que vous connaissez les les uns
et les autres à travers vos bureaux
d'aides sociaux des situations locales
chacun les connaî bien donc ça laisse du
temps et ça a tenu la ça tenue la mesure
donc nous ça serait la proposition que
je pourrais suggérer et elle est simple
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
court du gouvernement attendez attendez
mais attendez attendez parce que j'ai
beaucoup de demandes de parole je vais
attendez attendez j'ai encore beaucoup
de demandes de parole alors madame le
ministre vous voulez la parole je vous
en prie merci madame la
Présidente moi je vais me me rallier à
cette solution de compromis parce que je
pense qu'on est dans la dans la
coconstruction c'est-à-dire on essaie
tous les uns et les autres de de faire
des choses utiles à notre pays je pense
qu'il faut positiver le discours surtout
c'est-à-dire que si on commence par
faire la liste des obstacles ou des
inconvénients on va pas rentrer dans la
transition énergétique et ça va être
difficile sur le plan économique donc
plus les les indicateurs sont clairs
plus ça stabilise les entreprises et ça
c'est très important après il faut fixer
des échéance raisonnable 2030 c'est
quand même une échéance raisonnable et
je dirais même que ça protège les
propriétaires parce qu'ils ont cette
perspective là et on sait très bien que
plus le temps va passer plus un logement
qui sera mal isolé va perdre de sa
valeur et donc à à fixer un objectif
clair et en même temps à prévoir comme
le propose effectivement l'amendement
qui faudra bien les moyens financiers
d'accompagnement ça va obliger l'état
tous les ans de mettre les moyens
nécessaires à l'Agence Nationale pour
l'Amélioration de l'Habitat parce que
cette agence Nationale pour
l'Amélioration de l'Habitat vous le
savez vous qui êtes des élus locaux elle
est très efficace et elle permet au aux
familles aux personnes seules de revenus
modestes d'accéder aux travaux
d'économie d'énergie au meilleur coût
parce que du coup elles sont
accompagnées a a donc il y a un contrôle
aussi sur les les prix pratiqués par les
entreprises et ça a permis à travers le
territoire de de rénover plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de logements et
donc en effet l'idée de dire il faut un
accompagnement financier ça va mettre
l'État devant ses responsabilité au
moment de chaque année de vote du budget
de de l'ANA ça permet de faire un
objectif assez lointain je pense 2030
qui protège les les propriétaires et ça
permet avec la proposition du rapporteur
de la condition économique de faire face
en effet aux situations d'urgence qu'il
a évoqué et que l'on peut effectivement
prendre en considération donc je trouve
que c'est un que c'est un bon compromis
il faut avancer par étape et en même
temps il faut avancer avec détermination
et clarté pour que le mouvement de la
société aille bien dans le sens des
économies d'énergie parce qu'au bout du
compte ça protège les consommateurs et
ça protège les propriétaires qui voi qui
verront ainsi leurs bien
revalorisés merci Madame le Ministre
j'ai beaucoup de demandes de parole
avant toute chose Monsieur Dantec
acceptez-vous de rectifier votre
amendement ou est-ce que vous préférez
qu'on dépose un sous-amendement ben
écoutez je pense que il faut un
sous-amendement moi moi je propose enfin
si c'est moi je sais plus si c'est un le
même statut mais avec ce que vient de
dire Madame la Ministre les échanges
qu'on a eu avec Madame lettard et madame
linman je pense que si on met sous
réserve de la mise à disposition des
outils financier adéquat on répond
totalement à la question et ça répond ça
ça répond tout à fait à ce que vient de
dire Madame Royale de dire ça ça met
aussi l'État devant ses responsabilités
je même peut-être pas une phrase aussi
claire de la part de de l'État et donc
le sousréserve il est clair ça met
l'État et les collectivités l'ensemble
des de ceux qui accompagnent devant leur
responsabilité voilà Monsieur monsieur
Dantec monsieur Dantec est-ce que vous
acceptez de rectifier votre amendement
donc il n'y a plus besoin de
sous-amendement on est bien d'accord
donc on va rectifier l'amendement et je
vais vous donner à tous la parole mais
nous partons sur cette base là donc nous
rajoutons sous réserve de la mise à
disposition des outils financiers
adéquates tout le monde est d'accord je
reprends donc maintenant ma liste de
demande de parole monsieur le Président
de la Commission
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous avons
pris acte avec beaucoup d'intérêt de la
déclaration que madame la ministre a
fait pour essayer de trouver un
compromis on voit bien que sur tous les
bancs nous sommes attachés à ce que des
efforts importants soient fait en faveur
de la rénovation des logements il a été
décrit des situations que nous
connaissons dans nos villes dans nos
communes où des bâtiments ne sont plus
habités et deviennent de vraies friches
en cœur de bour et tout ça bien entendu
doit être corrigé puis en même temps
nous avons bien entendu que des ménages
des personnes âgées ne sont pas en
mesure de participer au financement
qu'elle soit propriétaire ou ou qu'elle
soit locataire
alors mon discours
euh je l'avais préparé avant
l'intervention euh de monsieur dantc qui
euh propose de modifier son son propre
amendement en fait il y a deux points il
y a d'abord euh les possibilités
euh des ménages des personnes âgées
c'est-à-dire euh la proposition que
faisait euh le rapporteur se référant à
l'amendement précédent si le calcul
économique le permet la assez bien par
rapport à la situation des propriétaires
ou des locataires et il y a une autre
idée qui est celle des outils qu'il faut
mettre en place notamment financiers
parce que le vrai problème madame la
ministre c'est que d'abord les outils
sont un peu disparates quelqu'un qui
veut rénover à plusieurs guichets de ce
point de vue-là en Allemagne on a des
exemples intéressants il y a des
procédures beaucoup plus simples et puis
surtout il y a des moyens financiers
qu'il faut mettre en place et la N ce
point de vue là et
aujourd'hui pas en mesure d'apporter les
des réponses aux personnes qui viennent
s'adresser à elle Lana n'a pas assez
d'argent mais vous avez dit et c'est un
point très important que nous avons
retenu le gouvernement entend bien
donner à Lana les moyens nécessaires
pour que ces rénovations puissent se
faire alors j'en reviens maintenant à la
proposition que fait ronand Dantec elle
ne couvre pas tout à fait
la proposition du
rapporteur alors c'est sur le second
alinéa donc cela voudrait dire cela
voudrait dire que la proposition du
rapporteur sur le premier alinéa reste
pertinente c'est-à-dire qu'il
complète le rapporteur le rapporteur a
bien dit à l'occasion d'e mutation
virgule selon leur niveau de performance
énergétique et si le calcul économique
le permet est-ce que nous sommes
d'accord sur cette rédaction je
continue la proposition que fait
ronalantech porte sur le second alinéa
où il introduit la notion de la mise en
place des outils financiers je dois dire
que cette proposition nous nous convient
également que les outils soient mis en
place qu'il y ait des financements pour
favoriser la rénovation des bâtiments
cela nous convient mais pour couvrir
l'intégralité des préoccupations qui ont
été exprimées il y a les deux
sous-amendements je me permets de le
souligner alors Monsieur Dantec
normalement pour l'instant monsieur le
Président il n'y a qu'un seul il n'y a
il n'y a plus dans celui qu'on vote
monsieur le Président il n'y a plus et
si le calcul comique le permet il n'y a
que sous réserve de la mise à alors si
vous voulez rajouter c'est autre chose
mais à l'heure actuelle nous discutons
sur ce sous-amendements c'est pour
répondre au président pour dire le
deuxème alinéa de l'amendement initial
dit un décret en Conseil d'État
précisera le calendrier progressif
d'application de cette obligation en
fonction de la performance énergétique
ét allé jusqu'en 2050 ça veut bien dire
que le calcul économique est déjà dans
le dans le décret donc c'est c'est
satisfait pour utiliser un terme
habituel
pas plus BES d'alourdir c'est prévu
aliné de l'amend avec le décret qui va
jus50 qui est extrêmement extrêmement
modéré donc il pas a pas besoin d'
rajouter merci Monsieur DC j'ai encore
des demandes de parole est-ce que
Monsieur Bourquin vous souhaitez
toujours la parole ou non très bien
monsieur
Barbier oui madame la présidente madame
ministre Mo je suis quand même
circonspect sur modalité parce que il y
a un autre problème qu'on soulève pas
c'est le problème de du niveau de
performance énergétique parce que pour
avoir beaucoup de d'expérience dans ce
domaine vous savez selon le cabinet que
vous choisissez vous avez une
performance énergétique qui peut varier
dans les proportions assez considérables
alors il y en a certains qui vont être
obligés de faire des travaux à partir de
2030 et puis d'autres qui vont voir
repousser ces travaux jusqu'à 2050 alors
alors c'est quand même très compliqué je
pense que il faudrait qu'on puisse avoir
des précisions sur les les termes du
décret qui seront pris en Conseil d'État
alors je sais pas si aujourd'hui on peut
avoir madame la ministre les idées que
vous aurez en écrivant ce décret savoir
quand est-ce que ce décret va sortir
est-ce que c'est maintenant ou est-ce
que c'est dans quelques années et là il
y av un véritable problème d'une
imprécision on est tous d'accord sur
l'intention qui est parfaitement louable
mais dans l'état actuel rédigé y compris
les amendements qui sont proposés moi je
je ne veux pas obérer l'avenir à ce
pointlà monsieur Barbier monsieur
Bourquin finalement vous voulez la
parole je vous en prie madame la
présidentead chers
collègues je pense que l'amendement de
Monsieur Dantec est est fait pour faire
la chasse au passoir énergétique dans le
secteur privé faut savoir que beaucoup
dans les cent-villes lorsqu'on a des
opas et qu'on fait des audits sur nos
centre-villees il y a beaucoup de
logements qui sont des passoirs
énergétiques souvent des personnes les
lou peu fortuné et se retrouve avec des
notes de chauffage et parfois des
charges qui sont plus importantes que le
loyer et donc l'amendement qui est
proposé a vraiment a vraiment une
qualité c'est qui permet de lutter
contre cela avec le
sous-amendement sous réserve que les
outils adéquats soient mise en place
est-ce que ça peut gêner le Parlement
que on on mette en place cet amendement
et qu'on vote cet amendement voilà si
nous avons cette mise au norme
si nous savons aussi que ça crée comme
ça a été dit tout à l'heure de nombreux
enlois dans le bâtiment et que nous
sommes à l'écoute de nos citoyens qui
justement se retrouve parfois avec des
AL vraiment des surprises terribles au
bout de quelques mois lorsqu'ils
habitent un hiver un peu froid comme
chez nous dans ces logements qu'est-ce
que ça nous gêne et on est sur
l'hypothèse 2030 qu'est-ce que ça nous
gêne de voter cet amendement et donc je
je pense vraiment qu'on devrait pas trop
perdre de temps sur des questions comme
celle-là en plus Renand d'ê a accepté le
sous-amendement euh votons-le et puis
faisons en sorte que on ait plus ces
passoirs énergétiques dans dans nos
centre-villees si Monsieur Bourquin
monsieur delè pour explication de
vote merci madame la Présidente moi je
voudrais saluer l'effort de recherche de
consensus fait par les uns et les autres
mais excusez-moi on est en train
d'écrire la loi la loi elle est
normative elle est pas déclarative elle
est pas intentionnelle qu'est-ce que
veut dire sur le plan juque ces
notions le calcul économique qui va
l'apprécier non mais attendez vous
m'autorisez à m'exprimer quand même
Monsieur D on vous écoute ici donc ayez
la gentillesse de respecter ceux qui
tent de
comprendre qui va apprécier le calcul
économique
ensuite la notion de réserve sous
réserve de la mise à disposition
d'outils financiers adéquat mais qui va
apprécier que les outils financi sont
adéquates moi j'aimerais le savoir le
gouvernement bien évidemment va nous
dire qu'il est adéquate mais ceux qui
vont mais ceux qui vont vouloir faire
des travaux vont considérreer qu'ils
sont insuffisants alors hier on avait
une nouvelle notion qui est apparue qui
était intéressante c'était à
l'horizon ce matin on ne parle plus
d'horizon on parle de déclaratif de
réserve d'intention et j'entendais à
l'instant notre excellent collègue
Bourquin dire mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a
de gênant à voter cette cet amendement
puisque on renvoie à 2030 mais c'est
précisément c'est précisément parce
qu'on renvoie à demain qu'on a pas le
courage de s'engager aujourd'hui que je
ne suis pas du tout d'accord avec cette
vision d'écrire la loi excusez-moi
d'être peut-être un peu trop juriste sur
ce point-là mais la loi elle est
normative encore une fois et ce que nous
sommes en train d'écrire c'est pas une
loi c'est un sal migondi pour essayer
tous de se donner bonne conscience à cet
instant laissant demain à nos
successeurs le soin de régler des
difficultés comme l'a si bien dit tout à
l'heure monsieur Dalier alors revenons à
l'essentiel de grâce et puis essayons
d'écrire quelque chose de simple
merci Monsieur Mel pour explication de
vote
oui si nous voulons atteindre les
objectifs louables que nous nous fixons
nous avons besoin de faciliter les
transactions c'est là que se pose à mes
yeux le principal problème nous avons
souvent des propriétaires qui sont des
personnes âgées qui partent en épad ou
qui vendent leur bien à un moment
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on veut vendre un
bien on est obligé de faire faire un
contrôle un
diagnostic termite plomb
amiante
énergétique il faudrait avoir un système
qui nous permette d'avoir un compte ô et
une évaluation des travaux assez
précises à réaliser dans un
bâtiment et au moment de la transaction
la personne qui veut vendre ne serait
pas obligé de faire les travaux mais au
contraire l'achcheteur saurait qu'il a
l'obligation de faire ses travaux avec
un système d'aide approprié et
lisible cela faciliterait grandement les
transactions et l'atteinte des objectifs
merci Monsieur Michel je n'ai plus de
demande monsieur Vassel oui je te don
très sucintement madame la Présidente
j'adhère tout à fait à ce qui a été
exprimé à l'instant à la fois par mon
collègue de Lille Villen et par notre
collègue mckel ceci étant il y a trop
d'incertitude et de vagues dans la
rédaction du texte à mon avis il est pas
acceptable en l'état et comme il le
disait à l'instant même il faudrait
plutôt reporter ça et laisser ça au soin
le soin no succè
d'en définir les modalités ce d'autant
plus que lorsque vous précisez que à
l'occasion d'une mutation ces travaux
devront être réalisés la question se
posera de savoir si c'est le vendeur ou
si c'est l'acheteur et enensce de ça
mettre sous la réserve que les les les
outils financiers soient définis on ne
sait pas du tout de quels outils
financiers il s'agira et de toute façon
vous trerez toujours un propriétaire ou
un acheteur qui considérera que les
outils financiers ne lui permettent pas
au vu de sa capacité financière de
réaliser ou de ne pas réaliser les
travaux et la question qui se posera ça
sera surtout le retour sur
investissement des travaux d'économie
d'énergie qui ont été réalisés et qui
rendront les travaux acceptables et
supportable par la personne qui
réalisera donc cette mutation donc à mon
avis la sagesse voudrait qu'on reporte
cela à plus tard et que l'on ne ne vote
pas une disposition de cette nature qui
n'a pas de caractère normatif comme l'a
dit mon C voilà pour ces débats dans
l'hémicycle sur le projet de loi
transition énergétique et croissance
verte vous l'avez vu les sénateurs
s'attaquer ce matin à un sujet
relativement consensuel l'isolation des
bâtiments c'est le grand titre 2 de ce
texte la transition énergétique c'est
l'un des projet de loi phare de ce début
d'année un projet de loi également très
consistant avec plus de 900 amendements
les débats doivent durer jusqu'à la fin
de la semaine prochaine avec un vote
solennel début mars vous pouvez toujours
voir et revoir toutes les séances sur
notre site publ ena.fr très bonne
journée à vous sur les chaînes
parlementaires